The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the flashlight.
If you go to Joe Rogan.net
and click on the link for the
flashlight,
you will get 15 percent off the number
one sex toy for men.
Oh yeah.
And that's what you say right?
When you shoot your load.
Thinking about the discount.
Oh,
savings.
Buckle up.
You dirty bitches.
It's my birthday.
And Ari Shaffir.
Yay.
The inevitable slide continues as I hit
44 today by the death of the slide
towards the great.
Beyond.
It will not stop.
It waits for no man.
40th four.
Which one is the 44?
That's what I just turned that.
Is that a special year when the goes
back,
just keeps going.
Keeps sliding.
I always say that I keep my eye on
semester stallone.
He's my canary in a coal mines.
Long As.
As long as that guy's still alive.
Like how much Roy can you do and be like
60.
That's incredible.
We would further line for expendables
too.
You know what he's like?
He's like an old fucking Carla.
You can take an old 55 Chevelle or a 55
buick rather,
and just put some ridiculous rocket
engine in it and,
and you know,
and fucking see how long that suspension
last brand new parts all over.
God's done brand new parts,
but how long before he blows that frame
out,
how long for the frame just bends and
falls off.
He must have like the best scientists in
the world just constantly jabbing him
needles,
just constantly checking his blood as
eating breakfast and somebody comes in,
sticks out,
someone else comes and draws some
checks,
his blood checks his urine,
the examine them,
and then they hit him with some more
roids.
Make sure you eat a grapefruit and shoot
it up.
Give them some of that shit from the
planet of the apes.
Give them that new shit.
Dude.
He's my canary in a coal mine,
so as long as I'm 44 and he's like 65 or
something like that now I think he's 65
to still do an action movies.
Seen that movie.
That planter there will be fun.
Yeah.
We talked about last podcast,
Doug Stanhope and canary because he
drinks he everything.
Yeah.
That's kind of the way he got in a lot
of trouble recently.
I guess I've gotten in trouble for
something.
I'll go on.
He was,
I believe BBC radio in the host of the
radio show.
Just mentioned one of his jokes and,
and uh,
the,
what is the disease?
The Red Down Syndrome.
This is what he said.
He said,
Sara,
this is
Stan hopes.
Joe Sarah Pailin has to retarded kids.
One of them has down syndrome.
The other ones signed up for the
military.
That's a fucking good job.
It's both with,
what did I say?
Lucy American Dj just mentioned that he
a panel.
This is the deal.
He's on BBC radio,
which I've done before and they were
very polite and you don't go into depth
about anything.
There's no flavor to it at all.
Yeah.
BBC radio is like the most bland flavor
list.
Emotionless.
It's like pbs accent.
It's like pbs.
If it was tired.
Yeah.
PBS.
If he got neutered,
if they had no Saturday.
Oh,
it's fucking terrible.
Terrible radio.
Uh,
but stan hope did it and he's talking to
this,
you know,
the,
they can't get an in depth about it,
so he's forced to have sort of a polite
conversation,
but he doesn't want to give the people
the wrong impression that this is going
to be like what they come to see,
you know,
when people don't know what kind of
comedy you do and Stan hope is,
you know,
remarkably offensive and especially if
you're just some regular fucking square
out there living in the world,
you know,
especially in England,
you're not used to this Arizona trash as
Doug Stanhope,
you know,
so he,
they wanted to let the people know like,
just in case you don't believe us,
that Mr Stan hope has a very offensive
standup comedy.
Aca.
Just Google his bid on Sarah Pailin.
That's all they were tired of it.
They just said see the bid on youtube
or.
Yeah,
I think he got in trouble for that.
Yes.
He got to find even go on that show.
Well,
what he's saying is that what the people
are saying was that what this guy did in
referencing that is like sort of like
what extent,
what's the rule?
It's like you don't condone it.
Yeah.
It's like condoning it by telling people
about it at all your advertising.
It sort of.
Which I can see that what they were
saying,
but so fucking what on the level of this
is present material.
He's telling you that it's offensive if
you don't believe in washes bit.
So if you don't believe him,
you know and you've watched the bit and
you get offended and then you get mad.
You're a fucking moron.
That's one of the dumbest fucking thing
I've ever heard in my life saying I'm
not taking your word for it.
Going there.
I'm like,
wow,
I should have taken your word for it.
It's outrageous that anyone could
possibly complain.
This guy is interviewing a comic.
Okay.
And in the interview,
the comic stains within the lines of
whatever parameters a behavior,
they,
they find acceptable.
He doesn't go out of those lines at all.
Just polite conversation,
but they wanted to let people know,
so he said,
if you don't believe us,
watch this bit,
and then people were going fucking
crazy.
They're calling for this guy's head.
It's incredible how.
What is going on?
Why is everybody becoming such a bunch
of content and pussies because it feels
like more than ever.
So they do.
Is that that?
Is it right?
Is it frustration and their own lives
and they find something where they can
score on something where they can
fucking tee off on.
They just go at times.
It really is like A.
I didn't want to hear that and it's
fucking annoying.
Fucking annoying.
But if it's during their faith,
but I think usually it's just like,
wait,
is that yes,
you shouldn't be promoted event anyway.
And if people just go overboard,
like I don't even want to exist in the
world.
They get mad whenever anyone references
is trying to kill it.
Yeah,
it's that too.
But it's a self righteous indignation.
It's just so fake.
Yeah.
There's so many people that are looking
for a moment to be angry shit on other
people for the end.
So you're not Christian enough,
you're not anything enough.
Whatever the fuck.
And that's all it is,
is just a.
it's just a religious thing.
That's all it's left.
Why the fuck is it so hard for people to
leave other people alone?
It's telling you it's offensive stuff.
Yeah.
All right.
If you're,
if you're into Jesus or whatever,
I just don't watch it.
Why is it so hard for kids to watch it?
Even if they watch it and they get
upset,
like,
Oh God,
he said that guy's an ass.
I'll never go see him live.
Mean why do they get so upset?
They attack the DJ from mentioning it.
I mean,
you gotta be you gotta be a fucking
mess.
That's what you're going to.
You're going to use your time for that.
Like really?
That's ridiculous.
Who does,
what does the house was?
I don't know what it is.
I Dunno.
I Dunno who the fuck does remember that
lady that Patrice O'Neal was fighting
with on MSNBC or Fox News?
Yes.
Yeah,
like that type of woman.
She represents the people who complain.
Yeah.
What the fuck man.
It's just like,
oh,
you don't even really understand what
it's even been said.
I was talking to this woman and she had
told me in the middle of the
conversation about some letter that she
wrote to some,
some something I forget it was a show or
a product and shit,
but she was going off about how,
so I wrote them a letter telling them
that I didn't.
I didn't find the Algo really.
You wrote them a letter,
like really the only reason to do,
to write a letter to accompany is for
the back to school reason when I'm in
summer school with Mark Harmon wherein
you get free shades and things like
that.
Yeah.
Writing a letter I remember hearing that
you all to do is complain.
I got some bunk Gillette razors.
What's up?
I think you're razors rule,
but this is bullshit
all the time and they were mostly
restaurants were the best because like I
would go to a restaurant and even if it
was just mediocre,
instead of just writing a review,
I'll just send a letter to like
applebee's.
Like dude,
I went to applebee's.
The waiter was like,
coming 20 minutes for a soup.
Really?
They'll send you a gift certificate back
for $50,
and I'm like,
ah.
Ever seen anybody in person trying to
run that scam and a restaurant?
What complaint?
Fake scam.
I've seen real complaints from like
Jewish Delis,
but there's plenty of people that
complained like this soup is cold or
this,
you know,
corn beef is rough.
That's,
that's all legit.
I mean,
I had to send a Pastrami Rueben back
once at Jerry's famous deli.
It turns out they cut it the wrong way.
It wasn't bad,
but if you cut it one way,
it's real rough fight,
right?
Yeah.
But if you cut it another way,
it breaks up,
which is incredible when you think about
it,
right?
It doesn't.
Doesn't brisk is the same way you got to
go with the greater.
It gets good.
I forget which one is you just move your
hand like to the left,
but what it is is cut it.
When you cut it with the tendon,
like w go along the grand attendant,
which is apparently the wrong way.
Then it's like chewing these tendons,
tendons,
wrong word,
muscle fibers,
but if you cut it against it,
I guess,
then it comes to that brisket he showed
me.
He was like,
look,
if I cut it wrong and give me a little,
just takes.
It just
bites rotten.
Wow.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
Fuck,
I was going to say something.
You sent that back.
You can play.
That was the one that was the only thing
ever.
Yeah.
The people that are much more important.
Wow.
I'm.
Oh No.
This is what it is.
I watched this happen in a restaurant.
I was at spa,
which is an excellent restaurant.
I mean spargo in,
in Maui,
in Hawaii.
It's really expensive.
It's the four seasons and it's a five
star restaurant.
I mean it's jamming.
The food there is intense.
It's really good.
It's one of those places where you can
puck,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The chef there.
Yeah.
You,
you eat there like they have this miso
cod or like you easily.
God Damn,
this is fucking delicious.
It's just they're experts.
They're experts,
chefs.
So,
uh,
it's a high end place.
So there's a lot of rich people,
they're dying in this little,
you know,
you look around and you know,
I'm on vacation.
I'm like,
how much money this guy,
steele,
who was this corporate criminal,
you know,
it's that kind of shit.
And at this restaurant,
the people behind us,
there was this English couple and they
were totally work in a scam.
It was so obvious.
One of them,
the guy was like,
you know,
he kept saying like,
you guys,
you've got,
you've got gotta,
get your shit together.
Here he goes,
I've come here,
I've aborted,
get to poke sharp.
You tell me you out the pork chops.
But the pork chops your special like,
mate,
how are you running out of this?
I mean,
this is shoddy,
shoddy stuff.
And the guy's like,
well,
I apologize Sir.
But hopefully the choice,
you know,
and,
and so he says,
you know,
our food didn't come at the same time.
Like hers was over,
you know,
he said it was like 10 minutes later was
at Gordon Ramsay.
No,
no,
no.
It's just some Dick.
And he was asking them to take money
off,
like surely you can't expect us to be
paying for this.
And he started talking about the rice
and he goes,
he goes over rice have rice racer.
So hot,
almost benton mouth mate is this.
We sent,
we sent,
they send something back,
we send it back because it's cold.
You bring it back.
It's too hot.
Like come on man,
get your shit together.
Might.
He goes,
this is intolerable.
you've got to,
you've got to do something to,
you know,
to fix them.
Sends us.
Yeah,
to whatever the word is,
you know,
to do something to make things right.
And I was like,
wow,
to compensate us,
you know,
you've got to compensate me for this.
You know?
It was like,
really?
It was ridiculous.
And they kept going and the manager,
it was a clumsy one.
Like they were there being way too
honest about it and the,
what they were complaining about was way
too little.
It was of the.
It's like whether you should get up and
leave immediately.
It's not like you're halfway through the
meal.
Then it got bad.
You're complaining from the start.
Well,
he was coming.
They were combined.
They complained about a few different
things.
It took me a while to tune into them.
There was like a certain,
like certain country noise from behind
me,
so it took me a while to tune into it
and then once I tuned into it,
then we actually watched them try to
scam these waiters and then,
you know,
the waiter had to bring over a manager
and the waiter clearly said to the
manager that these people are scamming
because there's,
the manager came back.
He was like a stone face killer.
It's like,
how can I help you?
What's going on here?
And the guy that runs this shit,
he'll sir,
we're out of the pork chops.
Any other questions?
What can I help you with you?
Like he just like kept them like,
I'm,
I'm confused.
Here is why you would
think that we would compensate you for
that sir.
Like,
why would you,
why would your meal isn't satisfactory?
This is an excellent restaurant.
I don't know what you're saying.
I can just shut the guy down.
And.
But it was ugly,
man,
that lasted for like 15 minutes and it
required everybody to pay attention to
it because it was,
you know,
when you're in a restaurant and all of a
sudden some shit goes wrong at some
table and you hear people raise their
voices like you have to pay attention at
least part of it because someone might
pull out a fucking gun or somebody might
punch somebody or commands your
attention,
but your,
your warning signals go off.
At least mine do.
When I see people arguing,
I always say,
okay,
what is,
what's going on here?
How much do I have to pay attention to
this?
What is the threat level I'm assessing
here?
You know,
when people are in the middle of a
fucking yelling at each other.
So I had to,
I had to pay attention to these
scumbags,
but it was weird.
It's weird singling people running
scams,
like it's one thing to be a kid in Ohio
trying to get fucking free lollipops or
whatever.
You want to be.
A grown man in his forties with a woman
who was clearly in on it and they're
trying to work this shit.
I feel bad.
That's the idea is that when he was
younger he robbed banks and mugged fags.
But I feel bad about my past but it's
not as bad.
When I used to do the scam when I was
like 18,
17,
I would go to these diners just to smoke
cigarettes and drink coffee and I had no
money and so what I would do is once in
a while I had chest hair when I was in
high school.
Once in awhile I would just be like,
oh,
who wants free meals?
And I'll just poke it.
And it goes.
Do you guys want some,
you know,
and that'll give it to my friends.
And you know the drill.
The yes.
How many times?
Probably like four or five.
Four or five times at the same place.
Yeah.
Tj is on High Street,
does it?
There's a dude that I know that actually
brings clipped nails to restaurants and
drop them in soups and this food that
people may put that in there and they'll
complain about and again get his and he
does it on purpose and he's.
He gets paid well this guy have it.
Pay Him.
No,
no,
no.
This guy is not a broke guy.
Poor guy running a scam.
But he brings a little plastic bag,
a little ziploc bag of nail clippings.
Me and my friend Shane once I went to
Arby's and you know there's a fountain
drinks.
They have these little black nozzles and
if you've worked in a restaurant,
it's like what you usually take out to
clean every night.
I put it in and twist it.
Anyways,
we got a drink and that black nozzle
fell into his glass and so we went to,
we went home and this is like when I
first got a video camera and he opened
it up and he was like,
what is this thing after he's drank half
of it,
so what's this thing?
And he pulls it out and stuff,
black nozzle and inside it is just mold
this most disgusting shit ever.
So we filmed it and we went to Arby's
and he's just like bitching at the
manager and uh,
and like we filmed the whole thing and
he's like,
no,
I want some free shit.
And like it was,
he turned it into like,
I wasn't going to pay me.
You're not going to bring it up.
I'll bring it up.
And the funny thing is she wouldn't give
him any really anything.
That was an internet video.
Yeah.
In the Internet days,
in the video,
she's like,
I don't care.
She's like,
here I'll give you a dollar back for
your drink and get a dollar back to the
drink.
And he's like,
are you kidding me?
We could send this to the fucking news.
She goes,
I don't give it,
you know,
I don't care.
Bluff.
I know.
And I have that video.
So she was right.
She didn't call,
you didn't do crap.
She's long dead.
But if you look at that video,
you'll come to sky did like it.
Yeah.
If it was the internet days,
I sent that picture of just that nozzle
to argue to find that video.
It's amazing.
The restaurants are as clean as we are.
When you think about,
you know,
all those fucking lazy people where
they're not cleaning up the restaurants.
They're not.
You ever see a clean kitchen nightmares
with one of the best TV shows every day
from Gordon Ramsey,
but I think they canceled it.
They have the UK version,
the American version,
the UK version or an American
restaurants.
Yeah.
Dara.
They go to places where they're just a
wreck.
Yeah.
But what sucks is like there's a
restaurant down the street from me in
Burbank that was on that show and it was
one of the worst episodes and in what
you can get on torrents.
But uh,
there's one Mexican restaurant where
they go in the back and I guess a lot of
Mexican restaurants do this.
They have a big bucket that they get,
like at home depot and they just put all
the beans in it and they had these
bucket of beans where they just scoop
out everyday and like,
here's your beans.
Here's your beans.
They show they pulled that bucket of
beans out.
One side of it was fucking mold.
The other side was like a breakthrough
where that hard layer and the top layer
was this.
Uh,
it was a Mexican restaurant on there's
mold on the beans.
Yeah.
Dot on one side.
It was mold in a top layer was so hard
that they broke through like ice,
like North Pole style to get the beans
underneath that.
We're still a.
It was exaggerating this.
If anyone's ever seen this episode,
they would know.
I think about every time I go to the
Mexican restaurant and they served it to
him in the show.
That's why this show is so great because
every episode he goes into the kitchen
and finds the exact same kind of shit.
It freaks you the fuck out where you
don't want to eat at a restaurant ever
again after watching that.
But it's on torrence.
Get a kitchen nightmares us version.
God Damn.
Yeah.
There's a lot,
man.
You do risk it when you go somewhere and
you buy someone else's preparation,
you do risk it.
You know the risk it.
I've worked in restaurants before,
you know,
whatever.
You got a shot at fucking pupil,
a curl that I was dating got in trouble
for spitting in someone's spitting in
someone's milkshake.
She'll get in a lot of trouble for that.
That ruins their faith in the system.
That shit happens all the time.
To do that as a waiter all the fucking
time.
Putting my balls on people's breadsticks
and shit.
I guess the dude was a Dick,
so she spit in his fucking milkshake and
that's always an option to be a dick.
Just don't do it.
It's so easy.
Don't.
Meanwhile she was kind of pretty.
Probably would have let her spit in his
mouth.
And you mentioned being a cop,
going to a restaurant.
Can you imagine being a cop?
Go into a restaurant?
No.
How many times people probably see a cop
walking into a restaurant and fucking
fuck,
fuck up that cop.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Especially some maids prison.
No one likes them.
Oh yeah,
man.
Ultimately became a meter maid.
Didn't even know.
I think for a little while.
Meet a mate is a terrible job.
You just getting negative energy all day
and nobody's nice to meet her raised.
It would probably change a world if they
would give them the option to stop
through a ticket if they actually could
do that and make some people's days.
Yeah,
right.
They can't.
Or can they?
They always say can't stop.
Once it started.
That was always the stereotype.
The cliche is true.
I don't know,
but if they could,
they went over so many more fans,
so God damn ridiculous that you have to
give someone money to put your car
somewhere.
Fuck you.
But without that,
no one will be able to get anywhere.
What?
So put up a sign that says you can't
park forever and then tow the flux.
It's that simple and it's one thing if
you live in like one of those places,
like in west Hollywood is kind of crazy
because they have all these spots where
you can only park if you're a resident
because there's really way too many
people for this area as the residence
would never be able to park and park.
There's too many for the residents as it
is.
There's too many,
there's just,
there's not enough parking spots for all
the cars because it's all these
apartment buildings and everybody in La
drives,
so if you look at an apartment building,
you're looking at one area that's not
that big on a block,
but might have 100 units at 40 people
for.
For cars,
that's 100 cars.
100 cars is like the whole block,
but there's a lot of other shit on that
block besides sides at apartment
building so it becomes a God damn
nightmare.
But that kind of makes sense.
Like resident parking,
like don't park it,
that's,
you know this,
these people live here.
It sucks if you want to visit somebody,
but that's better than if you lived.
If you lived there and it was
intolerable everyday,
he couldn't get a parking spot.
But to charge people for parking on the
fucking public streets.
Fuck you.
You know,
it's just,
it's ridiculous.
You shouldn't get any fucking money for
someone who's shopping in a store once a
pullover that fuck you,
you get it.
You get a dollar for that.
Why?
Well,
the biggest problem would be though,
if not doing that is then people just
abandoned their cars there in lights,
in their car parking or one hour your
parking.
There has to be some kind of
no parking for more than two hours here.
Making across the board that I don't
mind.
I don't mind if someone violates a good
normal rule and then you give them a
ticket to kind of keep order,
you know?
Hey man,
you can't just believe in your car
parked sideways.
Like that Douche bag.
You get a ticket for that.
But all the meters in general,
you're not leaders man.
Fuck that.
That's changed.
Especially the long ones.
Like if you go to la,
there's sometimes there's like 20 signs
and you seriously,
you just have to sit there and it's like
a video game for you to read all the
signs and you got to take it.
The last time we were in Pasadena
because it was like no parking for this
hour and this hour.
Tuesdays you can't park here at all
after this time.
And like I just need to take a.
You got to do the math.
You have to do math when you read the
fucking parking sign.
Yeah.
The thing is too,
you took a photo and you get a ticket
and what are you going to do?
You're really gonna fucking fight it.
Yeah.
It takes forever.
You're just like,
it's a fucking major ticket for much.
Is it?
It's like 60 or $70.
Yeah.
It's like there's no way,
and I always forget to do that work
because that's obviously doubles.
He would,
you know,
what really kills me is when cops have
quotas and no cops have quotas that they
have to reach over a certain amount of
people for a certain amount of things.
I'm pretty sure that's how it works.
Yeah,
and that's why I like certain times of
the month you'll see just nonstop cops
pulling people over all the time and
then next week you won't see anything.
But what's crazy is one,
if no one commits a crime,
I mean,
what if we got everybody to keep their
shit together for a month and these cops
still have quotas.
That would be a crazy movie like of a
town command.
If everyone comes,
fine.
Yeah.
If you had a big savings like boulder,
Colorado,
it's like 100,000
people.
If you.
You could almost get 100,000
people to never commit any crimes.
Don't like last week for one month.
Let's show these fucking cops that you
can't have quotas that say that.
You know,
some people have to be the last week.
Let's try to get everybody.
Unfortunately,
our laws are written in such a way where
you could pull you over for anything
they probably want to.
They,
they can find a way to pull you over no
matter what.
Like,
Oh,
you didn't turn on your signal three
seconds before you merged into the next
lane.
That's actually a law,
you know,
or something like that where they can
pull you up for a new instructor.
You know what I mean?
They get so mad when he,
when he would be with demoed for not
signaling.
Did you just say,
remember soul man and then the quota
scene.
That's hilarious.
Behind him.
When did the guy,
the white guy talked at tanning pills,
pills and turn black and was following
behind him and then eventually the
swerve.
Because I'm an open their door,
swerved around their door and the couple
of the lights on,
he was switching lanes without a,
without a signal.
How risky was that?
Maybe when that came out last time were
like,
whoa.
And then he started dating a black
check.
Whatever happens,
honored with a c Dot Thomas Howell.
I think of that.
What is it?
That guy?
Well,
that kind of vanished.
Yeah.
He's another Cuba gooding Jr.
A lot of those actors.
Do you understAnd that you reach a
higher level of consciousness and they
just kind of disappeared into the ether?
They like scientologists.
Yeah.
It probably did the right thing.
Their money and live on an island
somewhere and just get out of it,
you know?
That's what I would do.
I was in balboa.
If you ever heard a baobella island.
No.
It's this island off of newport beach
and it costs a dollar to get over on
this ferry.
It's awesome.
You just Drive onto this ferry that goes
right over.
It's like a kind of window.
Yeah.
It's just like lean is hard to get a
ferry,
right?
Yeah.
Your car over there.
It's expensive,
it's super small though in the houses
are fucking amazing.
There's not even a cop that lives on
this island and people just had their
doors wide open,
so you'd walk by and just see people
like sitting in their house and they had
a starbucks and it was the most peaceful
fucking shit ever.
I go in small numbers of people with
money tend to be peaceful.
If I got to a certain amount of money I
think,
I think I would just take that money,
invest in something that makes me money
every month and just fucking live
somewhere like that is this,
listen that,
this what the fuck he's an investor.
Invest in something that makes me money.
Every simple,
so simple like property renting out
property.
That's probably one of the easiest
things ever.
Not in this day and age,
man.
It's actually really hard.
In fact,
a reason why when you drive around and
see all these offices for rent
properties like housing departments,
this is a renter's market.
Believe it or not,
this apartments available everywhere,
which is really crazy.
Like what do they expect?
How many people do expect to move here?
I know there's so many extra apartments.
No,
fucking people are still coming,
you know.
When did you move here?
What year was it?
Ninety nine.
Did you do notice a discernible
difference between 99 and 2011 as far as
traffic,
unless you think is less now.
Less than like a.
I noticed this like a year and a half
ago.
It's way less than three years before
that.
This because he's just started smoking
weed and to look at it because were
sessions really actually noticed that I
had to stop doing a joke about that.
I was like,
why are the freeway so packed if,
if,
if everyone's supposed to be not
working,
but then I was like,
I'm doing a junk dude.
Keep doing that joke.
The freeloaders or gundam pack.
How I only noticed the opposite.
I'm like,
I'm getting to bray away faster.
Getting to all these places.
Wait,
well I think it's just luck.
I think that's just someone not
crashing.
You fly over in the four or five at five
in the afternoon.
You traffic.
It's just not.
doesn't seem as bad to me.
Orange county is the worst.
That area.
Like when you're talking about newport
beach for a quick.
Oh,
nice.
Jen down there is insane.
Anytime we got to go to irvine and the
irvine improv,
anytime we're doing that I'm always
like,
oh,
here we go.
I started going to karate up and around.
Really?
InsTead of going by the ocean,
I'd take the 2:10.
I go way the fuck out of my way.
It's like 30 miles longer.
Oh really?
It's way above.
But you cruise when you go away from the
ocean,
man,
that's when you can just fucking make
some traffic.
Movement.
You can make some movement.
You can get some progress done.
If you go far away from the ocean,
you got to go away from the ocean and up
high,
but as soon as you close in on that
ocean,
you get like five goes.
the,
the like.
The five goes the direction of the
ocean.
It's all along the shore.
I mean it's a couple miles in,
but it's along the shore.
It's You,
you're,
you're traveling the same way that the
ocean goes and it's everybody going from
Mexico to California and san diego to
California and every fucking weird town
in between.
There's all,
there's just too many god damn people,
but If you could go up to the to 10,
you go up high,
get 57 north and go up high.
You can actually move all around it.
It's crazy.
Yeah,
there's ways around it now.
California's it's way,
way,
way easier to get to where you need to
go.
Then like saint New York,
if you're in New York and you're fucked,
if you're fucked,
like say if you're in the bronx and you
need to get to manhattan,
you've got a couple of different bridges
you can take and they're both fucked up
or you can go in on the 95,
you can do that and that's going to be
fucked up too.
I said,
don't try.
Good luck.
Stupid.
yeah.
The city to get into manhattan is like.
I used to have an active case that they
made me taking.
This lady was always mad because I was
always like 20 minutes late and I'm
like,
look,
I'm sorry,
but it took me two and a half hours to
get all the time.
All the time coming from were coming
from new rochelle,
which is like the bronx.
Two and a half hours is normal.
You would get on that highway.
It was one of those.
They built highway so stupid on the east
coast.
They didn't get it.
They didn't know there was gonna be that
many people there.
So these highlights are all like fucking
three lanes on each side.
Four lanes at the most.
They don't have these giant expansive
four or five style eight,
nine lane highways.
They don't have them.
They're small,
especially boston,
like Massachusetts turnpike.
I go on the turnpike when I go back home
and I can't believe they call this a
turnpike.
It's fucking two lanes on each side.
It's ridiculously small.
There's like,
it's such a small little ass shitbag
road,
like the way to get to the cape just
like my god.
It's a little tiny ass road.
They didn't anticipate that shit at all,
but that's not that long ago,
man.
Think about it.
The invention of the automobile was only
100 years ago.
Right.
A little bit more than that.
It's like the early,
early 1800 does that when it was.
When did Henry Ford.
No,
1900 excuses were always move right up
to the roads immediately.
When did the automobile get invented?
Nineteen 41.
Yeah.
No,
no.
Holocaust automobile.
It's say the autocar was this
motherfucker I needed.
Is there a car like an suv that gets
super awesome gas mileage like a Korea
or anything like that or running
[inaudible],
author of god's knowledge,
like an suv type car,
yet have hybrids.
Three hybrids.
Wow.
Sweat this.
The first fucking steam powered vehicle
was designed by this dude who was a,
a flemish member of a jesuit mission in
China in 16.
Seventy two.
Really?
Yeah.
It was a scale model for the chinese
emperor.
Wow.
It wasn't even built a carrier driver or
a passenger,
but this guy figured that out in 16,
72.
That's fucking incredible.
And then in 1750 to some russian dude
constructed a human pedaled,
four wheeled auto running carriage and
propose to equip it with an odometer to
use the same principle for making a
cell.
Would it take,
once you sign that steam power model
till you just fuck it,
put into practice in a real car?
Eight years today?
I dunno,
I have no idea.
But it wouldn't take it off.
It wouldn't.
It wouldn't take as many years as it
went back.
Now back then you had to make somebody
accountable.
Something similar.
You gotta make your own tools to work on
it.
You know about that.
Can't go to hechinger yeah.
You can't just fucking go out a
business.
I forgot about that name.
A crazy with that.
But you would have to make a machine and
then make the parts and then make the
fucking tools to work in the machine
called blacks enough.
So apparently it was like they got it.
They got their shit together where,
you know,
it was like the,
uh,
the late 1800 seems
like they started really,
really rocking it.
Yeah,
I thought it was.
Um,
I thought that ford,
Henry Ford invented the car.
We're always taught the first class
manufacture because it says that Germany
was the first,
the first automobile powered by its own
for stroke,
a cycle.
Gasoline engine was built in mannheim,
Germany in 18,
85.
Could you imagine how fucking weird it
must have been,
like even thinking about other countries
that are on the other side of the ocean
and 18,
85.
I mean when we think about Germany or we
think about eating england,
at least for me,
I've been there.
I've been to both of them a couple of
times and when erica succeeded,
people in england were like,
I don't even know anyone who's even been
there.
I don't even know anyone who.
Nobody knew it because if you went
there,
you never went back.
You know,
it takes too long.
It's months like how much does it take?
How long does iT take on a boat to get
to America?
A long time.
Right now.
a lot of people for a week.
Right.
And a lot of people die along the way,
but that took a boat here.
Oh yeah.
My grandparents to my grandparents both
came by boat snaking who did not know he
was.
It was a.
They let jews into.
They don't even need green cards.
If they come on in,
we need more juice.
Yeah.
But if you're an arab or a mexican,
they go,
hey,
In that room over here.
That's true.
You don't already doing more amazing
racist.
But yes.
Are you really interested?
So found the jews are.
Brian said that with a um,
an unhappy tone.
Did you hear that?
Hold on.
I worry about.
I worry about little hurry.
What are you doing?
What's,
what are the next ones?
A jews.
Okay.
That's good.
That's goIng into those.
Yeah.
I went to a jewish market,
white people and generally easy to pick
on.
You should go only after white people.
It's hard.
I thought for years of how to get your
whites and I can't think of anything.
There's no angle Because i'm offended as
a race.
What are you talking about?
It would have to be an individual thing
like marriage,
your thoughts,
no flavor,
but how are you that won't,
that won't get them mad to say,
look at me pointing out that white
people have little dicks.
So what you're sayIng,
what an angle to do for a sketch.
yeah,
let's throw it up on twitter,
man.
People will come up with an angle for
you know,
but the thing is would have to make the
magic of seeing it like,
like the klan makes black people imagine
the only way it's going to be Megan
White people mad if you make black
people move into the neighborhood and
start partying.
Yeah.
That's what makes it.
That won't offend them as a race of
white people and white people see that
at home.
They won't get offended.
Right.
I see.
What you're saying is the people in that
neighBorhood will be upset.
You do racist shit around black people
like were a kkk outfit and they want to
beat your ass.
They're offended,
but you can't do this by the image.
They get upset about it.
Yeah,
it's true.
White people dominated,
unfortunately a lot of white people.
That was cool to say unfortunately,
but look,
if you want to look historically,
I'd way rather be on the team when.
Yeah aNd
yeah,
and as far as like giant groups of
people that run shit.
What are the optIons?
Is white people,
black people,
asians and arabs,
right.
Those are the options of giant groups.
People that are running
shows.
Yeah,
right.
That's the those entire groups and if
you look at all of them,
it seems like if America is the one
that's run by the white people,
seems like you can get away with the
most corporate crime,
but it seems like a pretty hard on the
other kind of crime and China,
you get away with a lot of corporate
crime,
bootleg stuff,
just a.
It's so easily because they're humaN.
Racist.
Camouflaged.
Did you hear what they did?
What?
They had
fake apple stores selling fake apple
products and the employees and the
people that were working there actually
thought they were working for apple.
Wow.
They didn't learn one and it's actually
not against the law for them to do that,
but they have to get the special permits
and only three of the stores are two of
the stores actually had the permits.
The other ones didn't.
Isn't that hilarious?
Yeah,
but if you looked at that like it seems
like China would be waste oppressive,
but then you got to look at it and go,
well yeah,
maybe it's because there's a billion
fucking people over there,
man.
If you've got a copy of the fucking
matrix.
Yeah,
I guess copy it and felt that people
have got other shit to worry about when
there's a billion fucking people and
everybody's eating bugs.
There's no food.
No.
You go over to China,
man.
Eat bugs.
That's true.
He a lot of other things,
but they eat a lot of bugs.
It's real comment.
If it kimchi,
soya sauce,
third babies in bottles.
Really?
what?
No dairy.
I was like,
I love kimchi,
but it's so spicy.
I think it's funny how babies have taste
buds though for for certain shit.
Like my littlest baby,
the one that's only a year and three
months,
she loves spicy shit,
chilling.
She grabs pepperoni and I'm looking and
I'm like,
oh,
she's going to hate this.
I can be more like.
She got some hot sauce the other daY and
loved it.
Which one?
The little one.
She doesn't.
Don't have the burden buds yet.
He says it wasn't real hot.
It was like tomatillo,
but it was.
It was a little piece of chicken and she
fucking duggin man.
Wow.
Trainer now.
Spicy garlic sauce.
It was a.
It was like a really garlicky sauce.
She was licking it up.
She liked it.
It's weird.
Right?
But the other one man,
fuck,
you can't give her anything.
She just start crying.
Supervisees by z,
like mild ass.
Indian food's super mile and she'll
start crying.
I made my grandfather's pickle recipe.
We did it again.
Me and taylor didn't pick it.
I didn't put it in five times as much
through salt by accident,
but five times too much.
We have,
when we made them,
I put two cups instead of like,
like two pinches it.
We like something ridiculous now.
But I still try to eat those pickles.
I'm like,
I made.
I'm not going to give him a go at this
time.
It came out right there.
So good.
And they're so spice that you got to
sweat under the eyes.
Really?
Yeah.
It's so good.
But it's.
Oh,
I was wondering was it wrong?
And we would eat one because we spent
like,
what a month doing this shit.
Leave my son and then we're good.
Uh,
my favorIte all time hot sauce is l you
could deca shit.
The mexican hot sauce had that griddle.
The green habanero.
That's good.
It's so good.
I forgot how good it was until we
started doing fear factor again because
the caterers always have.
Oh yeah.
And the caterers had something I threw
on some connie side of
the other day.
I'm like,
damn,
this is good.
It's just so flavorful and powerful.
But that's like the real legitimate
mexican shit.
Got to spanish label.
That's the real shit.
You can get to like thirty cents a
bottle.
Yeah.
It's amazing how many different cultures
have just like so much different flavor
to their foods.
You know,
like mexican food,
so I was like,
we,
you know,
there's a certain style of laboring and
eating.
Yeah,
spicy as fuck.
Some of their salsa is incredible.
And then,
You know,
you look at like irish food,
it's like boiled potatoes,
boiled corn,
beef,
boiled sauerkraut.
That's why the italians have via with a
lot of,
it was a result of like,
um,
industries and stuff.
LIke with allianz,
rural,
poor [inaudible],
they just made pasta.
It's the cheapest,
easiest stuff to make them and fills
your stomach and they just may shape it
differently.
That's the only variety you get.
As my shaping it slightly differently.
It is really amazing when you think
about how the food defines how people
behave to connected to how you feel like
they behave like italians are all about
passion and their food is very
passionate and rich and delicious and
flavorful.
But then you go to the irish and the
ever say anything to bear and they're
just watering themselves down with beer
and smoking cigarettes.
How ugly the women are.
Like,
hey,
my mimo irish people listen to this
podcast talking about,
okay,
I'm ugly too.
Were all ugly but a passionate to mike.
Northern Ireland is the craziest place
I've ever been where you drive around
and it was fighting.
Well,
there's a lot of fighting in Ireland.
I saw a lot of fighting,
but one of the things in northern
Ireland,
it was really crazy,
is that all the car,
the cars are armored.
They all have these giant plates of
steel all around because they had to
deal with a lot of bombings.
Will ira thing,
the protestants versus the catholics.
It was like there has been a,
most people in America are unaware of
how much Ireland in northern Ireland,
how much they went through,
you know,
there was a incredible amount of
bloodshed over there.
And because of that,
like when we went out,
um,
I did a gig with my boy dave bishop,
and then we went out and we went into
some fucking local place and the cars
that were all around us,
it was like we were in a fucking mad max
movie.
They're all like old old cars.
No,
they're all covered with steel.
Like their,
their armored,
like they have guns,
the windows for bombs.
And the windows of the cop cars had
steel mesh over them and it was like
plates and plates in the front of the
car and plates on the side.
They were like these big armored fucking
crazy shelves over there,
cop cars.
I was like,
wow,
what a fucking weird places.
And you couldn't understand a god damn
word anybody said it's amazing that they
call that shit english.
I talked to some dude in a club.
We were in the bar downstairs at the
hotel we were all staying at and we were
all drinking with this dude and he was
talking to me for two hours and all I
heard at a whole,
the whole two hours.
The only words I heard was I didn't
fight any mind talking to me about bias.
There's rockland chocolate down.
I'll tell you right now.
How's.
Hi tiny tiny man.
Just drinking and talking about how to
fight anyway.
He really would.
He would have fought anyone,
anyone in front of it.
It was just got his ass.
How the fuck?
Come on,
let's turn handed to him.
He'll bite You and fucking tried closer.
Call your eyes out.
So dreary over there,
man.
I've never eaten at a place that had
worst food.
Northern Ireland,
we had chinese food there that was like,
it was literallY like dogs and cats and
pigeons.
Who was fucking terrible.
Was it porridge good?
At least it was there anything that was
good.
You can't fuck up eggs.
So I had a lot of eggs there,
but it was,
I mean it could obviously be just where
I went,
but the parts that I went,
you know,
I got the worst food ever and we stay at
a nice hotel.
Food Is terrible.
No.
Wow.
Yeah.
They just like,
it was off like you're eating the beef
and you're like,
what the fuck is wrong with his beef
tastes?
This is a piece of steak,
but it tastes like completely different.
Like in Australia,
their beef is completely different than
american beef and it's good.
It's very good.
Don't get me wrong.
Australia's fantastic.
Sydney.
I've been to sydney twice.
It's amazing.
No,
because I've had free range to.
I eat grass fed beef.
That's what most of the time I ain't,
I,
I like corn fed because it's fattier.
And you get a little bit more fat in the
cooking,
but this is a flavor to grass fed that I
prefer and it's a healthier animal for
sure because when you're giving them
corn that is completely outside of their
diet and in the natural world,
it's a grain as opposed to a grass so
their bodies get super fat and
disgusting.
That's why they're so delicious.
That grain fed grass fed meat is
actually fat burner really.
Does that makes sense?
The opposite effect on your system makes
sense.
Because we're not supposed to be eating
an animal that's been forced,
fed some fucked up food to keep it fat.
You know,
that's a weird thing man.
But the difference is,
you know,
the food over in Australia,
like the beef was delicious.
The steak was delicious,
but it was like pink inside.
It was like a piece of pork chop.
It was a completely different shade.
Yeah,
it was a way lighter shade because like
when I get a medium rare steak,
you cut into it and you see that juicy
red fucking savage flashing.
But meanwhile this was like a pork chop.
I was like,
this is like white in there.
It was very good,
but it was like,
this is weird.
You know,
england,
it looked like steak.
It looks similar when I was cutting it
open,
but it tasted different.
It tasted like,
like,
like it was sick or something.
I just don't put any spice in or
something.
None in england.
Excuse me.
Northern Ireland.
Um,
I've had some great food in england.
people say that the food in england is
bad,
but it's nothing compared to northern
Ireland.
I've had some delicious restaurants that
are going on in england's got some great
places.
It's just,
you know,
when you go to a place is different.
Yeah.
You know,
like when you go get breakfast,
like english breakfast,
you get an english breakfast,
they bring you beans.
Crumpets?
Yes.
Awesome.
They're pretty good.
But english breakfast they give you
beans and and they call bangers bangers
or sausage and like a broiled tomato all
the time.
It's always,
I don't get that roiling the tomato,
but it's super common.
Falling apart is that they're good.
Zenko falls apart a little.
It's just,
it's a little cooked,
but I don't get it.
I don't know what.
Just give me a piece of fucking tomato,
tomato.
Do you have to improve the flavor of
tomato by cooking it?
I wonder if that's something I started
making zucchini.
If you grilled zucchini,
it tastes kinda cool.
You know,
tastes different.
have you grilled tomatoes.
So just not better,
you know,
I don't know.
I don't know either.
I've met a scottish comic,
it was like a 23 in montreal.
You couldn't understand a word he said
possible.
It was like people were trying,
like laughing at the idea of his accent
and then it was just like,
we don't understand any of this and it's
all english.
It was amazing to watch.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's interesting that the english
language has,
if you,
you go to all these different parts of
the globe.
Yeah.
And hear the variations from like
southern Georgia to northern Ireland,
you know,
and you hear the variations of the same
words and what,
you know,
what they,
what we use and don't use may really is
almost like,
it's a bunch of different languages.
Like it's getting close,
it's getting close to like morphing off
into its own separate branch if,
if people are separate.
The thing that fucked everything changed
separately.
Yeah.
But they're,
they're connected now.
You know,
now it's like people are inexorably
connected with the internet,
with mass media.
You,
you can hear the way people use those
words all over the world and they're
going to stay.
They're going to stay reasonably close
to the way they are now.
But if they weren't,
if people weren't connected,
you know,
there were separated if buy big chunks
of water or something like that.
Yeah,
they're there.
They would probably develop to a bunch
of different languages.
Yeah.
Probably over time.
Because you think it's a scottish ever
read?
Um,
a transporting?
Yes.
Written in.
Oh really?
You know,
it's written in vernacular.
It's like you have to like piece
together what they're saying.
It's like eventually that would sort of
become the written language and then
eventually certain words that you have
completely different words like the lift
in england for the elevator.
He would just start using those words
and it become a different language
though with our numerals or something.
Some guy was,
uh,
there was some,
some guy was on the radio the other day
and he was talking about how diverse the
england is and how many different
languages are spoken in england.
[inaudible].
We were talking about the riots and they
were talking about 300 different
languages.
And I went,
what,
three?
I didn't even know there were 300
languages.
How many?
I thought there was probably like 30
languages.
There's like a bunch of indians,
much different indian languages.
Me and american indian or India,
India.
Really?
I think there's like a bunch,
like 30 or 40 minutes.
Jesus christ.
Some of those you might be able to
understand,
like if you know,
you might be able to send a couple of
others like spanish and italian because
a lot of.
Well how wacky is China?
There's a bunch all in the same country.
A bunch of different ways to talk
chinese.
I thought it's just too.
I thought it was cantonese and mandarin,
but isn't there various dialects of each
one of them?
We are little areas is so pure,
so person who speaks cantonese can
understand a person who speaks mandarin
at all or that's a completely different
language,
but I don't.
Fuck.
That's insane.
Well,
who the fuck came up with language
first?
We know what the oldest language was.
Mm,
no,
no.
We know about written.
We know the oldest written shit as far
as we know today is assumer.
They,
they,
they think it's the sumerian texts.
6,000
best.
The oldest shit we've ever seen written
down.
But what throws that into fucked up
makes it mexican questionables this new
thing they found in Turkey over the last
couple of decades,
they fund this new site and target
called go becky tapley and go go
beckley,
tempe.
And it's um,
at least 6,000
years older than summer.
And it's all like really intricately
carved.
And you know,
there's a,
there's a language that we don't know
though.
That's the thing.
This is 6,000
years earlier,
but they didn't find any language.
They just followed that survived.
Well,
who knows,
you know,
it's like when you find a culture that's
that fucking old,
you're lucky you're finding anything.
You know the,
the land eats everything.
If you left a car alone for 16,000
years,
there's no car left when you come back
to sand.
Yeah,
it'll give.
It'll get absorbed by the earth.
Slowly but surely one little speck at a
time.
I mean,
if you've ever gone to an old junkyard
and you see a car from like 1940,
literally it's falling apart,
there's holes in it,
it's dissolve,
it'll dissolve the earth.
What you did for the,
the metal just goes back into the ground
and metal just becomes,
it becomes dirt,
becomes a part of the soil.
You know,
when we look at a culture that's that
old,
you know,
you only find rock.
You're not gonna find anything else.
You might find some carbon from a fire,
you know,
you might find some arrowheads and shit
like that,
but it's got to be hard,
hard rock or fossils,
you know,
you're going to find like bodies,
like human bodies,
you know,
semi fossilized state.
This is too long ago.
You're noT gonna find any paper.
If they made paper,
good luck.
You won't find it.
You're not going to find any metal
tools.
Those are gone.
The earth ate those.
I thought it was something that was
really big the other day about one of
your theories about,
you know,
how civilization started over type
thing.
Uh,
I met that robot,
I've not met him,
but I saw that robot at disneyland,
the honda robot,
the how,
but I got to see it run and do the stair
thing and I'm looking at it and I'm
like,
one day this thing is going to kill me,
you know,
and stuff like that,
they're going to make robots that and
it's going to turn on you and stuff like
that.
And what if like the robots kill the
whole entire human race and then,
you know,
like a virus or something like that
destroys all the robots and kills all
the robots.
And in a thousand years later,
there's nothing,
all the,
you know,
robots turned the sand because they
disintegrate.
And then there's two people like humans,
like hiding in a cave somewhere,
you know,
living or the dead bodies and he's
smoking crack and then they make a kid
and they're like jesus and stuff like
that.
And they build the whole race again.
But they're so fucked up on crap.
It's stupid because they were like just
living a cave the whole time that uh,
then the human race starts over again,
we.
And then we try to build robots again
and then they kill us off again.
And crack addicts and the caves.
That's what I was thinking,
that disneyland,
that's the entire
plot of battlestar galactica.
The cylons take over its end.
You know what?
It's a very possible plot.
The idea that we can make intelligent
life and we're super close to doing
that.
We're super close to having some sort of
an artificial intelligence that you can
communicate with that actually even
developed some motions they're going to
have like an emotional response is
programmed into these fucking things and
to,
for us to be arrogantly assuming that
that's never going to be a problem
because they're not really live there.
Not really,
but if we create a system that responds
as if it was alive,
you know,
if that system has self realization,
now that system become sentience and
realizes it has to protect itself and
then it defends itself against another
system that is just as alive as a virus.
It's just as alive as an animal that
wants to eat you.
It's just as alive as anything that's a
live band.
You've created something that exists
right now.
Yes,
it may not have cells in bone as you
think of life,
but it's responding and moving and
interacting and it's intelligent and
you've actually made this fucking thing,
a brain.
You've built this thing,
the ability to interact with other
brains,
other technologically created brains,
and you've got a whole network of
beings,
beings that have it within their best
interest to keep you dead and I'm alive.
That's all super duper possible.
It just seems so foreign to us.
It seems preposterous because our lives,
our whole lives.
The way we have looked at machines is
like,
this is some shit people made.
We have full control of it.
We have full.
We're,
we're out.
We're completely arrogant about it.
We have full control over the stuff we
make.
Have you ever seen that robot run as it
leaves the ground for us?
Just like a human.
When you run,
you actually there's a point where
you're both of your feet are off the
ground.
It does the same thing.
It was.
It was amazing.
It's amazing and it's just the
beginning.
It's just the beginning.
It's like I,
robot I,
robot is going to be legit,
man.
They're really going to have a robot
that as is as functional as a human
body.
It's gonna move like a human body,
but it's going to be metal and
replaceable and you know,
it's gonna.
It's gonna have artificial tissue that
won't break or rip or tear,
but it'll look like human tissue.
It's going to be incredible.
It's just a matter of time.
If you look at 1800 and what people had
in 1980 and 1900 and the beginning of
this century in 2000 and then compare it
to,
you know,
a thousand years ago,
there's obviously been some radical
changes in 1900 to 2000 to 2011.
There's radical radical changes and
those radical changes.
You took the,
the cream of the crop shit that we have
today,
like a fucking helicopter and uh,
uh,
nine slash 11 turbo and you brought them
to 1600.
There's no way of leonardo davinci sat
and looked at that.
He could have ever a nine slash 11
turbo.
He would get in that thing.
it'd be like,
what the fuck?
Like wow.
Really this is fucking crazy.
Like think of someone who like davinci
invented so many crazy things,
you know,
is had pat drawings for flying machines
and all sorts of different things that
he created.
But if you showed him what actually
occurred in our lifetime,
which we completely take for granted,
going towards it,
it's like space 1999 shit.
It's like,
it's like science fiction.
So for sure,
if these guys are making robots like
this honda robot,
which is amazing,
in 2011,
2000,
211,
fuck man,
it is going to be like blade runner as
long as I'm the you might not be dead.
That's the crazy thing with the science
and technology the way it is today,
you might not be dead at all.
There might be a renewed pill where you
can take within our lifetime that renews
your cells and reprograms your dna to
behave as if it's young.
They don't.
They're going to watch someone have a
vaccine for aging at some point so they
haven't had it.
You have to take it.
We're not really babies and people
haven't got the vaccine.
Are all gonna die.
Maybe that's a possibility.
It locks them all go.
More likely they'll manipulate the fact
that the cells recreate themselves every
seven years.
Everything except the neurons is
completely replaced every seven years.
So what they'll do is they'll reprogram
all these,
all these cells to come back fresh and
young and that's what they'll do.
So over a seven year period and you'll
take this shit and over seven year
period you'll go from being some old
lady to some hot young 20 year old bitch
him or if he just.
That'd be cool if he or if he just
didn't get older,
you know,
like whatever time you took that
probably because I doubt you're going to
be the beginning.
Oh it will.
It will.
No,
no question about it.
If you will.
Just think what I said,
if you're a tissue could recreate
itself.
The thing is you got to get it to
recreate itself in a state that's not
damaged like scars.
Right.
I'll give you think about if you have a
scar.
That scar.
I have a scar,
a big one on my finger that I got when I
was like nine.
So that.
But that scar is still here when I'm 44.
Why is it still here?
If everything's recreating because it's
recreating in damaged state.
When you would have to get your,
your cells to not recreate in a state of
an old person who's,
you know,
fucking engines misfiring.
You want to get into a mature person of
around 25 years of age.
Physically,
that's what you want.
I think it's more like they're just
going to take your head off robocop
style and put you on a robocop body and
then you're going to find a way to like
highs your brain.
Oh your shit,
and I don't think it will be a
biological solution of against to that.
I think it'll be a matter of recreating
your consciousness in a form of like a
computer code.
You know,
if,
if an operating system works for the mac
and operating system works for the pc,
what?
What the fuck is a human being?
What do you know?
What?
What is the driving mechanism behind
what makes a person want to eat and fuck
and and be successful and be curious and
what it.
What the fuck is under the surface?
Is it just a bunch of ones and zeros,
and if it's not,
is it possible to exactly it with a
bunch of ones and zeros?
That's the real question.
Is it possible to take a human being's
consciousness and completely recreated
to the point where all of a sudden
you're switched on and you know you're
switched on in,
in this body,
like you wake up one day and you don't
even fucking know that you are a
computer code and a machine and that
your entire life is absolutely,
completely 100 percent artificial.
It's just being fed to thIs computer
code through this,
you know,
this program that someone has created.
That's,
that is all,
that's not like completely ridiculous.
that's not like is even as ridiculous as
time travel and that's not ridiculous.
You know,
I mean the elder,
there's some scientists that believe
that you can never bypass the speed of
light,
so time travel will be impossible,
but I think they just say that for now.
I think there's,
there's nothIng that's going to
eventually not be possible.
I think It'll just be a matter of how
much power can read we generate in order
to manipulate our surroundings to make
everything possible.
It's a matter of time.
It,
like I said,
you know what's impossible today was
not.
I mean,
what,
what was impossible 200 years ago is not
impossible today,
so when you hear scientists saying that
this is impossible,
that doesn't mean it's impossible.
It just means as far as what we know now
and we don't know shit,
you know,
we know a lot.
I mean we're brilliant and comparison to
caveman,
but in comparison to understanding just
the very nature of the universe and when
you,
you know,
subatomic particles and they lose all
fucking rules,
go out the window when you go subatomic,
you know,
they have things called we're a particle
can be in a,
in a super state where it's in a state
of moving and it's still at the same
time.
What the fuck does that even mean?
And the idea that you can look at
something and as you're looking at it,
you change the behavior of it and then
you can watch an event and the observer
actually changes the actual atoms that
are,
that are,
that are moving in the fuck.
How is that possible?
We don't know.
so to say that people know a lot and we
know a lot for people,
we know a lot for people,
but there's some shit that we don't
understand at all.
They don't even know why the
universities together.
They don't know why it doesn't just fly
apart.
You know,
this dark matter thing is like they
don't.
They don't know what the fuck that is.
That's just guessing.
It's probably just with vinegar or
something like that.
They've realized it is probably douche
vinegar.
You know what they figured out?
They figured out that there's some sort
of an anti matter like layer to the van
allen radiation belts,
that there's a layer of anti-matter out
there.
I don't even know what the fuck that
means,
but that's incredible that there's some,
some shit that they've been talking
about using for weapons forever.
They've been talking about anti-matter
weapons forever because if you could
conceivably create an anti weapon
anti-matter weapon,
it would be just as big of a leap as
nuclear weapons were two arrows.
Yeah.
Things just fucking go.
Bye bye.
Just cool to imagine.
Imagine if we went to Afghanistan,
if they tried anti-matter weapons on
Afghanistan and we went there in
Afghanistan was like a bowl,
a ceramic bowl like white and shiny,
and there was literally nothing else
there.
It was like the whole thing,
which is white and shiny like ceramic.
That's not outside the realm of
possibility because we were like,
we already.
Yeah,
yeah,
we did that.
Everyone is.
When I realized that I talked to tony,
but it was like everyone's like,
oh,
we can't trust the russians with nuclear
weapons.
We can't trust the chinese.
The koreans.
It's like we're the only ones that have
set.
Set them off.
We're the only ones that we did it
twice.
Oh no.
Russians have detonated them for
practice against people.
Yeah.
We're the only ones that people and
we're like,
oh,
we can't trust them with them.
We can't trust us.
We're the ones who can trust as us and
where these are people that existed a
long time ago.
I mean,
the idea that we're at with those douche
bags,
I do shit.
They didn't just blow up zillions.
the.
The word is that the japanese were
trying to surrender for a long time and
he said no because he wanted to test it.
Well,
they wanted to fucking do it.
It was not really a task.
They wanted a letter by.
No,
it's up twice.
Drop bombs and car alarms.
The idea that you're going to take this
fucking thing that harnesses the power
of the sun and you're just gonna drop it
on.
Some people you don't even know and it's
okay because we're at war.
This is like,
it's not a.
These are soldiers.
These are just some people going about
their business.
Yeah.
People are politics and then all of a
sudden they're just.
They're obliterated.
They never were any crazy.
Didn't even know jet engines back there.
They did their propeller plane
and they dropped it out of this
propeller plane and then had to do a
three 60 or one eight.
8 million fucking get out of there.
Is that what they are?
Do follow like physics bumped follows?
Which?
The planning how high up when they let
it go?
I don't know.
It's amazing.
They have video footage of that,
of them doing it.
They must've got fucked up by radiation.
No,
probably right.
Probably hit it.
Fucking went to so many people that got
fucked up by radiation.
How long did,
how long those guys lived?
It's a good question.
Well,
they,
you know the.
You've seen,
we've talked about.
I talk about it on stage,
the videos of guys running towards the
blast and the army where they used to
blow off bombs and have them run towards
the bomb.
They did that a lot,
you know,
and obviously that would never happen
today.
Have you tried to get an american
soldier today to run towards a blast to
shoot you in the dick or.
Yeah,
he's like,
what?
No one's come out of there,
man.
I'm going to run towards effort test.
We know now the average person knows
that shit will kill you.
OfficEr kerr dashi and I want you to run
past that.
I watched the kim kardashians
commercials showing some clothes that
she had and she was talking about how
she likes this look and likes that look,
and sometimes they wear this and I wear
it with a dress because it.
I wear it with a jacket because it makes
it a little bit more saucy yet and I'm
like,
wow,
who's the wise?
Anyone?
Thank you.
vapid.
It's amazing how many people sponsor her
or how many to credit her face is on.
if you walked through jc penny's or
macy's or whatever it is,
you'll see her face a million times for
a million different products and
magazines,
right?
Yeah.
Every fucking magazine has her face on
the cover.
It's incredible.
The girls making bank,
you can't hate her for that.
You can't hate it for any of it.
I don't hate her.
she's just so dumb.
It's so amazing that we have fixated on
this and you know,
she has a very pretty face.
Don't get me wrong,
but it's always getting worked on like
every now and then it'll get all puffy
and shit because she's getting
injections and there's all these before
and after pictures.
It does look good,
but it's,
you know what I'm saying?
It's like there's certain girls that
just looked like,
like angelina jolie,
she has this face where like,
especially when she was young,
like you just look at eagle.
Wow.
That is a perfect symmetrical face.
Like I can understand that face being
everywhere and this girl,
kim kardashians,
she's pretty and she's,
she's hot,
she's got some big titties and ass and
everything.
It's all good,
but it's not good enough to be focusing
so much time on it.
It's not that.
It's like people are addicted to her.
It's like it's cigarettes,
so cigarettes aren't that good.
you know,
you smoke one in the beginning we've
never smoked a cigarette,
like why would I keep doing this?
But after awhile you get addicted to it
and it becomes something you're used to.
Now it's like these magazines are
addicted to putting kim kardashian
everywhere.
It's like you're making a big deal out
of absolutely nothing.
She's just a person.
It's not bad.
Not hating her.
She is the girl out there,
you know,
getting her is by being in a show that
follows her around.
BuT once you start following someone
around and you start tuning into that,
man,
it's,
it's tricky.
It is like addictive.
They become a.
It's like you get programmed with
wanting to know,
well,
there's a conflict going on with her and
her sister's boyfriend.
I wonder how they're going to resolve
that.
You want to watch them.
You just can't help it.
She just tried to sue a old navy because
a friend of ours,
um,
are our friend.
Mine is melissa mala narrow,
uh,
nor was his friends that have a breeze
and I don't think you ever met her.
But uh,
she uh,
was on an old navy commercial and she's
singing and dancing.
It was a commercial and a,
the kardashian.
Kim kardashians said,
no,
that's,
people think that's me.
You know?
Uh,
and so she tried to sue old navy.
I don't think she does kind of look
like,
or she looks like a,
a hotter version of the kardashians was
like,
how could you say that?
Hot.
It's ridiculous.
How could you say that this is what the
girl looks like.
You're not allowed to use this girl.
This girl looks like that.
But you're not allowed to use her
because she looks too much.
Like actually you should do ads for
them.
I don't think even if she did so fucking
one.
It's not like this girl is your own
face.
You can't.
You can't sue someone for using a pretty
girls face because that pretty girl that
happened.
So it was like you.
So what did that pretty girls never
allowed to work again because she looks
too much like you.
If they're tryiNg to replace her at the
chIna.
Like even so what?
So what dude,
if,
if even if they were trying to replace
her,
if this girl has her own face and this
company chooses.
You know what?
I like this girl.
She looks like kim kardashian,
but she's prettier and she's unknown.
Let's use her.
That they should be when more than
allowed to do that when they her as a
spokesman,
but
they use her voice anyway.
No,
that's definitely doable.
A perfect example,
say I'm what if someone decides to do a,
some sort of a video game or something
about fear factor and they have a dude
pretend to be me and he looks kinda like
me and talks kinda like me,
and they say it's me.
Well then I consider that a problem.
Then I can say,
hey,
that's not me,
but if you decide to do fear factor and
you go and get some dude who looks like
me and he's good at it and he just does
it,
I can't sue you.
He's just dealIng.
Even if he's imitating me,
even if he's imitating that replaces me.
If you replaces me and he's doing the
show the way I do the show,
I still can't sell them
all.
Right.
I don't know.
I don't think so.
I don't think it's wrong or they're
trying to pass them off as you.
Yeah,
but the kim kardashians.
Okay,
well what if it says,
you know,
fred fucking suck.
You know the host of fear factor.
This is this,
this is fred fucking suck just happened.
So we'll probably be the problem with or
another trying to pass it off as her
not.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
you can't.
I don't know.
That's why I asked if she was in middle.
Maybe.
Here's the thing,
you're protecting this giant
multimillionaire celebrity image when
there's a girl who just wants to work
and she happens to look like this girl.
She should be able to work.
This girl should not have to.
You know,
I can't.
She can't do a shoe ad because she looks
too much like kim kardashian.
Kim kardashian does a shoe ad and it,
you know,
it makes the case swiss people think
that she's cheating on them or
something.
Where the fuck she makes shoes for.
You know what I mean?
Like that's not,
that's not cool.
You don't own other people's face
because they look similar to you.
I'm like,
what if a chinese person tried to do
that?
Right.
There's no copyright laws in China.
But with what brian was talking,
I mean,
if they tried to do in America,
I mean it was brian talking about how
many chinese people,
there's so much less variation in their
appearance.
That's why there's no copyright laws in
China conveyed to you,
right?
Well,
not only that,
it's just so,
uh,
so ridiculous that you would be able to
copyright your image when you're images.
Exactly the same image as everybody
else's.
You know,
if there's a billion men in China and
400 million look like,
you know,
holy shit,
dude.
I remember buck rogers and that came on
that planet that everyone looked like it
was illegal to wear masks.
Realize lee will take your mask off
really because they want was everywhere
and crazy because all the boys looked
like all the other boys and other girls,
like all the other girls.
Buck rogers.
Is this like the really,
really old buck rogers?
No,
it wasn't a black and white.
It was with a,
it was with chewy or whatever the
metric.
The robot's name was a little guy that
walked waddled.
Chewy.
Not sure if it wasn't that.
It was like a twinkie or something.
Twiggy.
How many different buck rogers and they
did.
It was one of the silvers twiggy's
twinkies.
That cute little robot.
Yeah,
absolutely.
The robots back then.
We just.
I know the mom from supplements,
but maybe the robots would always roll
around photos role because we couldn't
see the move because they couldn't get
that tag.
You can just slide by you evenly or you
remember lost
in space.
Warning.
That robot,
that robot.
That was stupid as fuck.
He looked like a popcorn maker.
He had these big claws for fingers.
Useless fucking clamp.
By the way,
if it landed in any planet that that
robot gets stuck instantly.
If it wasn't completely paved even he
has no chance to to get around.
It was stupid.
Rolled around.
They had the technology to get to
another planet.
They couldn't make an effective robot.
A robot that can act like he's rolling
around.
Warning.
Morning.
That was the state of the art for a
while,
right?
Yeah,
and these fucking people were supposed
to be believed.
That just stuck out there in space and
they keep landing on places where they
could breathe the air.
Oh lucky us.
We can breathe the air out here and
they're hanging out with the one gay guy
that was the first gay guy on
television.
Remember?
He's always alone with the kids.
Yeah.
He was always alone with the kids and he
was always like the.
The father would fucking quiet them down
real quick and he would,
he'd be all upset.
Really.
My nap time?
Yeah.
And he was a never a threat to fuck the
wife ever.
No.
The wife was hot as fuck out there on
space.
Really supposed to be competing for this
one woman,
you know,
like in.
What is it?
I'm fighting the waking,
the walking dead series.
The two cops.
Oh yeah.
Fighting over the same woman.
That's how it goes.
And the real jungle bitches.
Sometimes it makes me wonder how I keep
from going under.
Yeah,
man,
if there's a zombie apocalypse,
I'd like to die,
please.
Oh yeah.
I just want to read.
Just trying to live through it.
If there's like a meteor impact and the
meteor contained spores that turns the
survivors into zomBies,
please land on my head.
Just let's get it over with.
Yeah,
let's end this nice and quickly,
please if you ever seen the road.
I watched it until the video I watched
bought the blue ray a watch it until it
was teaching.
The boy had to shoot himself in the
mouth and I said,
okay,
I've shut it off,
but I said raped before it gets killed.
I was like,
I don't want this in my mind.
I read the book.
Yeah,
I remember when you were reading it.
You were,
you were absorbed,
dude.
You were reading and we were on the
road.
He'd be sitting next to you on the plane
just like rolling his eyes.
Like first book I read in a decade,
it was,
uh,
maybe more of the maybe.
Uh,
yeah,
we were in the airport.
We're thinking to fly planes a day,
like seven days or that was the canadian
tour that went on.
You had no direct flights at all while
we were up in the boondocks.
Man,
we do.
We did a grand prairie and apparently,
uh,
all those weird spots,
we did like weird mining towns and shit.
I met somebody from,
from grand prairie.
I was like,
oh,
I played there once,
but they were like,
no,
you're kidding.
That's funny.
They didn't believe it.
Listen bitch,
we played like very light till like 1130
at night.
I'll go anywhere bro.
Go to grand prairie for the experience.
For the experience.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a weird place up there,
man.
You know when those weird.
Those are the spots that,
that people only get to go for a few
months,
a year.
It's a completely different.
And he challenged me to go to one of the
places in the winter.
You'd be crazy.
Don't do it.
He was like,
experienced man.
See what it's like.
You could die.
Die really.
I have a buddy,
one of the people that I work with on a
fear factor who did ice road truckers
and he went to someplace a up there
were,
they were uh,
driving there.
They drove the trucks across the fucking
lakes.
Frozen lakes,
like he's crazy shit.
40 beLow zero.
it was outside.
Wow.
Yeah.
He said he fucked up and left his gloves
in the car,
tried to manipulate something with his
hands.
His hands were getting stuck to the,
to the metal because it was so cold.
The fuck crazy man.
How raising.
there's no way to get laid in an
environment like that.
It have to go back to your house so
fast.
You couldn't even like,
I'm not going to a bar tonight.
Amazing.
Yeah.
Forty fucking below zero.
So in these places when you know,
you go there in the summertime,
man,
it's like there's a,
there's like a happiness to the people
are so happy that you could go outside
and not die.
Didn't you feel it?
You feel like a jewel all summer long.
It's everyone's like,
oh,
we just love this kayaking and breathing
the air.
Amazing.
I wonder if they appreciate life better.
I've always thought about that better.
No doubt.
We're always in the summer,
man.
I appreciate it that much.
Although I really do.
First time I stayed here,
man,
I stayed here with my friend Gary
Valentine when I was doing something for
mtv and they gave me a room with two
beds and gary was up here for some
audition to crash with me.
We got up every day and we were like
another fucking shitty day in paradise.
So we were in our young twenties,
like I was like 24 or 25 or something
like that.
And we were like,
this is fucking incredible.
Because we were living in New York where
every day was gray,
you know,
from good luck from october to march,
most of the fucking sky is gray and it
sucks and it's either as raining or
snowing or it just sucks,
you know?
So you get so used to this.
No rain,
no snow,
no have to deal with weather.
But I think that when you take out in
nature as a variable,
you don't have to consider nature.
People get like real cocky.
They get real.
You know what I'm saying?
It was just one of the reasons why the
la dude,
like when you think of la dishes,
at least I think of people who are,
I think of them as not just being soft
but delusional about their hardness.
Like,
oh,
he's an la douche.
You know,
la douche is like,
always think they're tougher than they
are.
Always think they're smarter than they
They always,
there was cocky.
There's something cocky and I think part
of that is because they're never humbled
by the weather.
Explain watts.
explain watts.
It's black people.
It's totally,
totally different.
Run.
I was talking about,
um,
I was coming home from a fire once when
one time we were filming fear factor and
we were driving and it was during the
crazy wildfires and flying home from a
firewall.
It was a fire.
We had a,
we had to evacuate and we had finished a
stunt.
We got done in time,
but when we got on the highway for an
hour,
a full hour of going 55 miles an hour,
like not fast.
No one was driving fast,
but it was highway speeds.
The whole right side of the highway was
engulfed in flames as far as you could
see it was crazy,
but one of the things I remember is how
polite everybody was.
People were using their blinkers and
people were waving and,
and I looked around and everybody was
scared and slack jawed when you deal
with snow,
like if you go up to Maine during a snow
storm,
I was driving up north during the
snowstorm and my car broke down and I
had to like hang out with the people and
the toll booth,
like they took me in because it was too
cold for me to be outside and they
hooked me up and.
But everybody was friendly.
Can we get you some coffee?
You know,
like every milan because tHey're all
banding together to,
you know,
because there's this fucking crazy thing
outside that can kill all the people's.
Not been my experience with new yorkers
involved.
Yeah.
There's a lot of the urban,
you know,
the urban pressure that comes with that
to the giant numbers.
Giant numbers of people is a problem
because people get dehumanized by the
pressure.
But I think overall people in the east
coast are more realistic.
They're more realistic in their
behavior,
more realistic in the way they think
about themselves.
They might be cocky and it might be
arrogant,
but there's a different different
version of it.
Then you get in California,
California is missing the element of the
weather.
You never have to consider it.
You never have to worry.
Like,
I just think it has the opposite effect.
I think you're just going to flourish as
a person.
You can do that too.
Sure.
I mean it's basically a in how you look
at it.
I don't think it hurts you,
but I think it might hurt a dummy.
You know,
I think when you're living in the east
coast and hurricanes come and you've got
to fucking batten down the hatches for
the hurricane you get out of.
It kind of puts things into perspective
when you get out there and you see trees
ripped out of their roots and fucking
windows broken and houses and cars
fucking flipped over.
Like that puts it into perspective.
Like you ain't shit,
you know,
and everybody better band together
because there's some other stuff out
there besides people and it can fucking
kill people and some of it is air.
How about that?
How about the air becomes a scary
monster that rips fucking buildings off
its foundations,
wipes out entire towns and people are
running around worried about vampires.
Fuck.
Vampire tornadoes are way scarier than
vampires.
You know,
a vampire can't just destroy your house
in here.
Who's wearing fat girls?
Girls and I'm worried they're hoping
they're hoping for a vampire.
I don't know if they're hoping they like
to believe.
Isn't it funny that they like to combine
those twos?
Vampires and romance were something
about him being undead is sexy.
Well,
I could never.
You could never leave you.
Maybe it's that.
It's also that you know the,
the,
the futility,
the obvious futility of the relationship
because unless he kills her and eater or
unless he turns her into a vampire,
she can't stay with him because she's
going to grow old and he's going to be
young forever and it's like this romance
and the fact that he loves her.
And you know,
just a metaphor for,
you know,
everyone has problems.
They'll be able to agree to spend the
rest of your life with a woman.
Yeah.
If you agree to make
that life in eternity,
how much more so romantic would that be?
Yeah.
And there's also the forbIdden love.
The fact that he supposed to be
dangerous,
but no one knows.
Everybody thinks he's a monster,
but you know the real him and around
you,
he safe.
But around other men,
he pulls his fangs on every runs and
they want to kill him.
But you don't know him and you're like,
look at yourself.
You're dating a vampire.
stop it.
She led a vampire fucker in the twilight
movies.
They've logged vampire.
Fuck the shit out of her.
Really?
Yeah.
Would you?
Would you fuck a vampire chick if she
gave you life forever?
A no.
What's some crazy big pitcher wants to
eat me.
Can you imagine?
Fell in love.
Now listen,
killed them.
Vampires aren't people you see when you
got to kill them,
you got to stick with 10 people.
There's a reason why we don't have
mountain lions.
Just wandering through our streets like,
you have pigeons.
Pigeons are helpless.
I'd go,
I'd go over immediately.
He fucker.
I go over and then start telling about
the people,
the mortals I know really telling on
them like I know where they live.
Do you say this in january?
Are you saying this in jest?
I would definitely become a mortal
really.
Why?
People want to live longer.
Yeah,
but what if when you die,
okay,
if we're talking about vampires were
talking about something so silly,
but if we're talking about vampires,
then we're talking about evil things and
we're talking about if you die,
you're going to go to hell.
So now hell exists.
If vampire's exists,
cal probably exist too,
but you're never going to hell because
you're on debt and you'd get killed.
You don't want to kill it,
and then your soul goes to hell.
Yeah,
you're fucked for each client because if
you accept vampirism,
they would have to accept.
Yeah,
you've got to accept all kinds of thing.
Damped by god.
Yeah,
you got accept a bunch of other stupid
shit that goes along with.
It just seems like god fucked up there
agaiN.
They dammed up to eternal life.
Yeah.
It's like,
that's pretty cool.
Another fuckup yup.
But isn't there a potion to off being a
vampire?
Drinks blood and then you gave up your
vampire power.
I don't believe that.
That's some shit where people make a
regular blood.
All these fucking pussy,
cutesy vampires with beautiful hair.
That's not what a vampire I suppose.
What does it take to?
The heart kills you.
It kills you.
Like garlic kills.
You try all sorts of different
variations on the vampire theme.
Like there's a book out called the
strain is a guillermo del toro and some
other book on camp.
It starts out bad ass,
but ultimately completely fizzles and
becomes stupid.
It becomes like almost like they ran out
of,
they had like 10 pages where they have
to finish,
so they just finished and then he shot
him and he died.
Yeah.
It's the sort of.
But in it's Weird and literature for
them because it seems like almost like
it's written by two different people.
One person was really new doctor.
He's a producer and director.
He's the guy who did pan's labyrinth
with a great,
great movie labyrinth.
Sorry.
um,
but it was,
this book is almost like it's written by
one person than the other person
finished.
It almost seems like because in the
beginning they set everything up bad ass
and it's like really?
And suspenseful
and you're like,
Whoa,
this is a good fucking book.
Like a real page turner.
Like I remember I was reading it,
uh,
in Germany and everybody else in the ufc
was going to go to some after party.
I purposely.
So now I'm kinda tired.
I went back to my room to read this book
because it was that good.
I was so addicted to it.
I stuck with it.
But then it turns into a stupid book,
like the last,
like 40 page story.
All of a sudden you're like,
what?
It didN't do that.
it just,
the detail was gone.
Like all of a sudden it was just.
And this happened and that happened.
I was like,
yeah.
What are you doing to fix in the,
in the movie?
Um,
I don't know.
I Don't think it's going to be a movie.
They were trying to make it a mini
series,
but there's a way they have billboards
up portland.
I posted bills.
Oh really?
Yeah,
for the strain.
Oh wow.
For the book,
for the book just came out.
No,
the,
the second book came out,
but that was at least a year ago,
I believe.
The second boat,
or maybe they're making a movie about
it.
Maybe.
I thought they were going to try.
I thought that I think the original
thing was a treatment for a mini series
and then they decided to.
He decided to turn into a book and sell
the book.
But like two days ago I started seeing
the bills for really strain the movie.
Let's google that shit.
But my point is and said it said don't
invite them in or something like that.
Or don't.
Don't have to.
Do you think they're already lands?
Labyrinth?
Porn version would be pam finally have a
trailer out already?
Um,
no,
I think they'll do better than that.
Really?
Oh,
there's a trilogy.
That's what it is.
I think it's the book was the sequel to
the book because it doesn't say
anything.
Oh,
the strain movie.
Hm.
So you're getting peed on brian?
Yeah.
Won't happen again.
Okay.
It is,
it's a real movie old del toro.
it's a real movie.
But my point about vampires is that
this,
these guys did another different take on
the vampire.
This,
this vampire didn't have fangs.
Yeah.
They always want to reinvent,
which I get,
but it's like,
come on man,
don't even attack your throat like a
regular vampire does.
They put a little tiny incision that you
can't even see.
You can barely see it.
It's so.
It's like a tongue.
Their tongue more.
Some like,
like little laser fucking razor blade
thing.
It's really dumb.
It's like nosferatu nosferatu.
The vampire is supposed to look like
that old one from the 19 hundreds.
The one that was like a,
it was a silent radio.
That's what they're supposed to do.
What it's supposed to look like.
The undead.
They're supposed to look like a horrible
fucking creeps and it's supposed to have
fangs and it's supposed to jack your
throat.
Everything else you're inventing,
you're just.
You're inventing a new thing.
Just didn't invite me in movie.
Yes or yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
Check from superbad or whatever.
Yeah,
that was pretty cool.
Yeah.
I saw the original version two.
I don't remember the name of it.
One of them's invite me and invite me in
as the american version.
I forget what the other one let me in
whatever it was.
I saw both of them,
but the thing about it,
it's about a girl,
girl,
girl who's a vampire.
It's pretty dope.
It's realistic forever or whatever it
is.
Apparently.
Gauge it is really cool.
I'm super realistic because.
Exactly what it is.
Super realistic.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
I'm not a great ending.
Not sort of happy.
It's sort
of like the american one wasn't as good
as the foreign one was.
Well,
it was close.
I wouldn't say it wasn't as good because
whenever you compare something to the
old something,
you always go this new batman's gay,
you know,
just it's just natural.
But there's that scene in a tunnel where
she jacks that old man.
Oh my god.
That was good.
And,
and,
and weird.
You know.
And the new one you mean.
Yeah.
And that's the way she did it was
frightening.
and that check is good.
Yeah.
But that's a real goddamn vampire movie.
That's how they're supposed to be.
You can't invent stuff like,
oh,
they can go out in the sun,
but they sparkled.
Fuck you,
man.
They radiate.
Not a vampire.
This is some,
some fake shit.
This is some fake shit,
man.
Goddammit.
Romance.
Real romance.
so speaking of romance,
your girls pain on you again.
Yeah.
I don't know what's happening now.
It happened again and it's like,
it's a nice piece.
No,
no,
no.
While we're banging,
when she comes,
it's just explodes.
And you know,
people sent me a shooting or is it pink?
She's either peeing or she's juicing so
hard that it,
it's the p levels of amount.
But you said it smeLled like pee.
It did.
It did smell like pee.
And uh,
but.
But what also I've been noticing is when
I'm fucking her,
it's gotten to the point where it's like
so wet that it's like making donald duck
noises.
I like thAt.
LIke it's filling up with so much
liquid.
Like she needs to go to a doctor or
anything because I.
You said she's a super nympho like she
liked vibrates in the car while she's
driving.
Yeah,
she puts a little vibrator.
Maddie's maybe she broke,
broke a voucher.
She wants dick like three times a day
and put poor.
Brian was forced to go to a gym now.
Yeah,
just trying to get in shape
because I can't keep up anymore.
It's so much.
It's,
that's three times.
Is the men by the or that she at least
has to have it three times god to any
you cave man fucking or are you just
whimpering?
Luckily.
Slowly slide it in.
Luckily I figure out a girl what she
likes and stuff.
You just had that one move that just
makes them come like crazy.
Well you just,
I just have to keep on doing that one
move.
Don't say the moon because then the next
boyfrIend will learn,
want to do it from behind and you're
choking her and you punch her.
You got to drop the elbow to the back of
that.
so wait.
So what happens if you don't do that?
like whatever,
like I just can't do it a second and
third time today.
Uh,
she gets mad,
she gets mad.
So I have to in my head I'm like,
oh,
that's not good because she's going to
go somewhere else and so I have to do
it.
And what I've been increasing my below
job,
I'd,
if you know me,
I'm not a huge blow job fan,
but I have to increase that because that
gives me some time,
you know,
to like,
all right,
I'm ready to do this,
you know,
because it sounds to go home.
Yeah.
So,
so it's now getting to the point where,
I mean,
like the other day it was like six times
and it was like fuck.
And then like 10 minutes later she goes,
fuck me again.
Okay.
You know,
it's hilarious,
dude.
this is like a scene from the twilight
zone.
This is like an episode of the twilight
is guy asks for it that much and then
then he kept fucking take it back.
She's like,
you better fuck me.
You better fuck me.
You fuck her.
She gets mad at you and you fucking
freak out.
Yeah.
It's like,
what does she do when she's gone?
Like on the roads and stuff,
she has a selection of toys by the way.
I don't know if you've ever heard of
upper women that there's this vibe vibe
or african.
Remember later,
but it's like an ipod for vibrators,
the vibrator and called.
I forget the name of the company that
makes it on the ipod.
What do you mean?
You just got a usb plug in it,
so you just hook it up to your laptop or
charges it charges and it's got like a
thousand things.
You could download settings maybe.
Yeah,
it's great.
It's crazy,
but yeah.
No,
yeah,
we'll take that vibration programs and
sort of be like,
you know,
you get on an elliptical machine that
simulates stairs.
There's a vibrator hard,
fast.
So she's constantly trying to get off.
Yeah.
Nonstop.
One hundred,
hundred thousand.
She,
she's seriously spends most of her time.
It's really good.
They did normal.
Well.
I always,
I always equate obsessive sexual
behavior with distraction.
I always say that when I'm.
Whenever in my life that I've been
obsessed sexually,
whether it was obsessed with
masturbating or obsessed with fucking
that it's a distraction and that really
I was imbalanced and what I needed to do
was get my mind in order and then fuck
anymore.
No,
no,
not that I wouldn't fuck anymore,
but that I wouldn't be obsessive.
You know,
there's a certain level of fucking or
jerking off or anything where you do it
even when you're not even horny,
you do it because this is the thing
you're obsessed with this thing you're
fixating on.
so like physically your dick is limited
edition.
You're not horny,
but yet you'll be chasing pussy like
crazy.
Whereas like there's a big difference
between that and like say if your
girlfriend goes out of town for a couple
of weeks,
I don't want to go back and it's been
weeks.
If you girlfriend goes out of town for a
couple of weeks and you haven't seen her
and then you grab her and you hug and
you kiss and your decal time and you've
had that feeling.
Then when you grab her ashley like,
oh fuck yeah,
that's,
that's real horniness
real deal stuff that I miss because I'm
fucking four times a day that now It's
just like,
all right,
must fuck.
That's what I'm thinking about your girl
too.
I think she can't really possibly be
experiencing that either.
She seems to be obsessing.
I mean,
I understand the concept of nympho.
I always wonder if getting all.
She's getting hard.
Yeah.
But it's different.
It's different.
It's different for a girl.
And so the whole setup is different,
but just,
you know,
it's not like a dick.
Uh,
dick is a highly complicated biomedical
condition.
You know,
hard on.
Hard on is if a guy had a bone,
you know,
like if your dick was a bone and you can
just fuck all the time,
you would wear the skin after.
I think it would look like a rhino horn.
It would just be pointing at the tip and
all broken down and scabby and fucking
hard and you'd just be fucking all the
time.
But because of that,
your,
your dick is,
it's really complicated.
Sort of an arrangement where everythIng
has to be in line.
You have to have the right amount of
sexual confidence,
you can't have too much liquor,
you can't have too many distractions or
bills.
That can be too much noise.
Nobody can be screaming at you.
You know,
if you had a horn,
a rhino horn dick,
you could just fuck you.
And people scream that you stopped
talking about as far as got a crazy
bone.
You never have to worry about it going
dead.
But anything can cause your bones to
stop.
You know,
you can get an.
Have you ever gotten in an argument in
the middle of fucking uh,
yeah,
uh,
thought of bill sometimes,
but it's really wearing on me or like
getting some parts just so distracted.
Like,
oh fuck.
And then you,
dick starts going lamp.
Yeah.
Well,
I've,
there was a girl that,
I did it a long ass time ago.
He used to argue about everything.
She always wanted to argue and she would
argue while we're fucking or fucking
should just start arguing and I,
I had to pull out,
I had to pull out and stop.
What's what I go,
you're a fucking crazy person.
what?
We're having sex and you can't stop
ours.
We start fucking her in the ass.
No,
no,
no.
That's when you run away.
Before she kills you.
You've got the wrong advice,
brian.
That's terrible advice.
Yeah,
so I don't know what to do.
I got a doctor.
Mainly it's,
I think it's a psychological thing.
I mean,
I don't know physically,
like everyone's different.
Obviously you're different.
Much different than me.
I'm much different than our world.
We,
there's,
there's level.
Some people are autistic.
I'm sure some girls are sexually just
chemically imbalanced to some point of
nymphomaniac,
like it's a physical thing,
but I also believe that a lot of the
cases of nymphomaniac is distractions.
Just like a man being obsessed with
beating off that,
you can call that guy a nymphomaniac.
A girl is just like having a rhino dick
because he's distracted or did you say
what you're saying?
What do you mean?
You're saying it's a distraction.
It's a lot of the reason why they're
doing it is because they're looking for
a distraction from somebody else,
from their life,
from focusing on your life.
If you have issues and things that make
you insecure things or where you're
you're.
You haven't accomplished what you want
to.
Things where you're not at a place where
you need to be emotionally or.
Yes,
yes,
gambling,
all those things.
They're all completely related to an
imbalance in your system and imbalance
of the human being.
when I get into the isolation tank,
the number one thing,
the number one theme when I get in there
is sorting out things that are bothering
me.
It forces me to consider all the things
that are bothering me.
The isolation tank is the exact opposite
of going to a hooker.
See if you got some shit going on like
gosh,
coast pitcher right now.
She's talking about dick for $500 and
you get crazy and you start going into a
picker friends.
I don't know,
I'm just making up a number,
but I know dudes who were addicted.
Doug.
I know dudes who would always lIke bring
hookers out to clubs and they would
always pick up hookers and had hookers
that were constantly texting them.
Hey babe,
I'm here.
And they look spent thousands of dollars
on her first and that those guys were
all fucked up in the head.
Like all of them.
There's all sorts of imbalanced.
It wasn't a horniness,
It wasn't.
It was an obsession and a lot of that
obsession is because you don't like
certain parts of your own life and
you're trying to not think about your
problems.
So instead of thinking about your
problems,
you think about beating off or you think
about gambling or you think about,
you know,
anything else,
like their cars.
Yeah.
Any.
Whatever the fuck it is.
It's become you become obsessed with
video games,
you know,
anything where you become obsessed the
point where it's not even enjoyable
would.
That is almost always is you trying to
avoid some shit that's really bothering
you.
You try and do ignore it.
It's evolutionary.
It's,
it's,
uh,
you're,
you're in a rut behavior.
You're like a crazy rat.
Sit in the corner of bobbing back and
forth waiting for your heroin.
It's completely unpredictable on
unproductive.
Yeah.
So your girlfriend is crazy.
We need to taKe your girlfriend to a
doctor,
take her to a psychologist or I may go
to one of those car washes with the
vacuum cleaner to suck out.
Sometimes people need to talk to
somebody about their shit.
I,
you asked her what it is.
If it's p while she's got some issues,
he doesn't know.
It just started like two days ago where
it's just,
I mean,
seriously,
when we're having sex,
it's really loud.
Is like donald duck on a,
on a carousel.
That doesn't bother me as much as the
constantly wanting to fuck all the time
when someone.
Cause I always think that this just fuck
me,
get me,
stop thinking about those.
JusT come on.
Fuck man.
I wonder if you know her
past and you know,
you've talked about her issues in her
past.
She really needs to go to someone and
sit down and talk to somebody.
That's what she needs to do.
I mean,
I think a lot of people need that man.
So it's not a bad thing.
It's not a weak thing.
Other people can help.
The problem is she talked about going to
a sex addiction anonymous type thing,
but the problem is I don't want her
Going there.
Were with other sex addict that just
seems like a bad idea.
You know,
you'll go there and some dude looks like
the new conan,
so I'm six foot four friend.
Swore the handsome bastard with giant
pectorals and a fucking iron chef dick.
I would say tHat if,
if,
if a girl looks like your girlfriend
wants to get laId,
she would have zero problems.
Addiction thing to pick up girls.
That'd be what I'm saying is if somebody
wants to fuck her,
she's going to fuck.
Shouldn't be to be around.
She's very unfortunate.
She can get dick at the subway,
throwing,
burning wax on her 12 inch,
12 inch chastity belt,
pussy eating,
going back to just listen,
stop,
stop being scared of.
That's proof.
Look,
you're gonna die.
Okay.
there's no stability to any of this
shit.
There's urgent and the sun's goIng to
die.
The son only has a billion years left or
whatever the fuck it has.
Six billion years.
Whatever the fuck they predict.
It's.
This is all temporary,
bro.
You're,
you're,
you're fucking this really hot girl.
Just enjoy it.
Be nice to enjoy it and get that bitch a
doctor because she needs a doctor.
She's getting,
she's wants too much dick.
It's ridiculous.
Or you know,
I don't know.
Whatever the fuck going on now.
I don't even have a vagina.
Men.
Men are such non experts in the vagina,
whIch no one has completely isolated
with.
Squirting is thinking about every single
fucking figure it out.
Yeah.
Every single function of the man's body
has been cleverly analyzed,
but woman's body has a lock.
That smile,
they're hiding something.
that's what squirting it.
Squirting is like the big foot of the
woman's body.
Like what is this is real.
What is.
This isn't a ufo.
Squirting is like fucking paranormal.
Well nobody knows what the fuck that is.
There's a lot of debate about whether or
not that's pissed.
There's a lot of debate about whether
you should be impressed by it or not.
Yeah.
Well you should drink a website.
I'm really trying to bring some next
time I'm here to look at it and smell it
and tell me what you think.
Smell it.
Yeah.
Bring it in.
I'll smell it on camera.
You tasted it.
We live it on your chest.
I'll rub a little around my nipple,
but those just for just around the
nipple.
Imagine if you made me like super
sensitive and I started crying into my
pores.
They say that men's loads actually help
cure depression in women.
That there is some.
Yeah,
believe it or not that there's.
There's somethinG in male semen.
What absorbed by the woman's body.
The reaction actually alleviates
depression,
friends and whatever.
So maybe that's why she wants dick all
the time.
It could be that a male scientists do
this research,
but yeah,
we should.
I should use condoms.
Condoms.
Wow.
Bill.
Really?
That's the problem.
That's what I have.
Not given any real dick.
that's what you have to tell him.
that's hilarious.
Semen acts as an anti depressant science
journal,
man.
This is a new science
to say how.
HoW'd your,
uh,
you just got an std test.
How did that go?
Hold on.
Sweat this before we get into that,
there.
Up until.
This is really true,
semen actually makes you happy.
The remarkable conclusion of a study
comparing women whose partners were
condoms with knows whose partners don't.
That's the problem,
dude.
You're wearing condoms.
Clank.
Yeah.
The study Is bound to pervert ca provoke
controversy.
Okay.
This is sort of anecdotal evidence.
They could have just got lucky and found
10 people are fucking.
Feels better.
I don't think simon makes you better
when you fuck without a condom.
It feels better.
You know,
you could just say that.
people heard girls calling it with a
condom,
calling it like it's like getting a
massage with your t shirt on.
Oh wow.
That's a good way of putting it.
Yeah.
That's probably why they feel better
about the relationships because the sex
actually feels really fucking good.
You know,
It probably has nothing to do with qa.
You should talk to.
People will pull out the.
But nobody wants to admit they pull out.
Nobody wants to admit they're so stupid
that that's their method of birth
control.
You know,
you could,
you could analyze them.
You know,
nobody wants to admit that man is a bit
from my act and it's absolutely fucking
true how I made my
first daughter that was 100 percent
pulling out.
That was all pulling.
I pulled the fuck out.
I didn't leave it in there.
I wasn't drunk.
I know what I was doing.
It doesn't matter.
There's some really determined sperm
that will make shit happen.
So don't,
don't try the pull out method.
Now you're so lucky.
Well,
it's hard.
It's not as easy to knock someone up as
easy thing because,
uh,
when we were trying to have the second
baby,
I fucked her a lot and I'm just shooting
loads in their dog.
Yeah.
But it took like a couple of months.
I was like,
jesus christ fucking you every day,
you know,
this is getting ridiculous,
rally the time when she was oscillating,
whenever she's obviously eating I.
It was a mall session of fuck the shit
out of like seven,
eight days in a row.
She said,
well,
we're going to make some babies.
I got fired up,
smoke a lot of.
We'd listen to some good music and go
and just fucking attack,
You know,
but it doesn't always work,
man.
It took a few months of that.
I shot loads and our every single day
that she was operating and it still took
months.
Eddie bravo,
you know it's taken him.
He's trying to have a baby.
I shouldn't talk about that.
And he went,
nobody wants to release that.
My girlfriend played practical joke on
me because she did that.
We got a birth control test the other
day at target and she got a red sharpie
and made the mark so it was pregnant and
she just laid it on the bathroom floor
and didn't say anything.
They say it's a practical joke,
but she probably wanted to see your
reaction because every girl,
every girl deep down inside wants to
have babies.
Yeah,
well I.
My actual reaction with god,
yes,
and I gave her a hug and I was like,
god,
it really no
manchild.
It's not quite.
If you really told me you had a baby,
I was like all flashed in my head.
Okay.
I got to get them to join the army,
get out of this now.
I was just shocked and I was thinking
about in can you get a guy in boot camp
without having them
being the actual arm?
I don't want them to go overseas,
but he needs to go fuck your right to
being a cook guy.
He needs to go to Afghanistan and
fucking run around with a backpack on
and become a man.
You guys know it'd be an awesome dad.
You wouldn't be a good day.
You're great with your,
your look.
He got so depressed that is cat hurt her
foot and he started smoking.
Okay.
He's very controlled.
You would freak out.
That's why I always tell eddie bravo.
He'd be a great dad because he's fucking
dotes over his bunnies.
BunnIes and white dude.
Wait until you have a kid that's so much
responsibility with kids.
They are.
They're an amazing procrastinate at all
with them.
No you can't,
but you know,
louis c,
k told me this once you get more shit
done when you have kids because you
know,
you don't sit around and just fart
around and think about getting things
done.
Like you only have a certain amount of
time like it forces you to.
Oh,
by the way tonight,
Doug,
stand hopes on louis.
Oh is.
Oh cool.
Awesome.
Um,
I saw doug on the greenroom episode with
the jury janeane garofalo and he went
after jenny groth.
Well,
because of the day after nine slash 11,
she was onstage and Texas saying that we
need to support the president's port
George Bush.
And that should change.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Of course.
Yeah.
No,
that whole fucking liberal intellectual
with one finger in the air and that they
send the check out the fucking political
wind blowing which ways of billowing.
I don't mind people changing their mind.
I told you kevin.
Then,
but then you're going to harshly judge
everyone who hasn't changed their mind
fast enough that she denied it,
which is much more interesting.
Oh really interesting.
To watch someone deny it.
Yeah.
And what,
there was video of it.
Well,
I had,
um,
what,
why you said it didn't happen and doug
was very adamant about it because I
remember him telling me about it,
how ridiculous he thought it was when it
happened.
At the time,
you know,
that the support,
any.
Why wOuld you ever fucking support any
of these folks that are running this
country?
They're all god damn Criminals,
their,
they're all.
Everything they do that's legal should
be illegal.
Everything they do that secret should be
open.
Transparency in government is the number
one reason why all the shake and take
place.
I've firmly believed that they have fake
spies and fake data breaches and fake
hacks just so they can tighten down
security and just so they can make more
things secret.
I really Truly believed that.
I think if I was trying to run shit the
way this United States government is
run,
the way they and what's you're
constantly taking money,
what do you think the reason would be
for them to all money and finding where
the money goes?
Oh,
hiding money.
WeLl look,
you know,
about this whole thing where there was a
bailout.
We thought it was a certain amount of
money and it turned out to be
$16,000,000,000,000
in secret bail outs.
Yeah,
because the ron paul and uh,
someone else audited the fed and they,
they got a detailed list.
You didn't hear him going to.
Couldn't be $60 trillion bro.
Look,
secret owe $800,
billion to trillion secret bail outs.
Hold on,
I'll read you the article.
And these are in mainstream publications
20 times as much as they might end up
the federal federal reserve or reveal
16,
$16,000,000,000,000
in bail outs.
This is not just on one site.
This is on many,
many sites.
And it's,
uh,
the first ever government accountability
office audit of the federal reserve was
carried out in the past few months due
to the,
due to ron paul allan grayson amendment
amendment to the dodd frank bill,
which passed last year,
and jim dement,
a republican senator and bernie sanders
and independent senator led the charge
for the federal reserve audit in the
senate,
but watered down the original language
of the house,
blah,
blah.
What was revealed iN the audit was
startling.
Sixteen trillion.
Brilliant.
Listen to this,
but there's a bunch of websites with a
very similar article.
But listen to the trillion,
listen to them.
And he zeros.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine,
10,
11,
12,
12 fucking zeros.
That is 16,000
billion dollars.
That's what that is.
So amazing.
And this is 16 trillion had been
secretly given out to us banks and
corporations and foreign banks
everywhere from France to scotland.
The period between December,
2007 and June,
2010,
the federal reserve had secretly bailed.
Many of the world's banks,
corporations and governments,
the federal reserve likes to refer to
these secret bay Laos as an all
inclusive loan program,
but virtually none of the money has been
returned.
Oh wait.
It was loaned out at zero percent
interest.
Wow.
Now why isn't this on mainstream news?
Why isn't this the sources that a lot of
different to.
Oh,
I'll find the ones whose website is
called the plain truth is,
but it's been on the daily cause it's
been on a cause.
Yeah.
K ios,
which is like a,
a real liberal.
I'm a news source,
but it was in the huffington post.
It was in her is in like,
I know secret panels,
huffington post,
because I know it was in that.
So we need you to collect that money.
Ari did the Bobby Lee choke.
Many people do voguing.
Huffington post is not too liberal rag.
That's.
It is true,
but okay,
let's go.
Yet the more reputable.
Try seeing overdose,
trust cnn.
Cnn has a too.
Yeah.
Sixteen trillion is what we said we've
spent on bail outs.
That's 20 times 20 of those in secret on
top of the one we did for real that
people argued against.
Yeah.
This one's saying 9 trillion this other
play press corp,
ca canadian website.
Same 9 trillion.
Either way it's okay.
Market observe,
observation.
There's a lot of websites that have this
story.
Well,
there's only one that has 9 trillion.
Everything else seems to be sticking
with between 13 and 16 trillion until
like totally adding it up.
Yeah.
There's,
there's a lot of websites,
man.
I mean the google hits.
I got 4 million,
200,000
results.
Wow.
So it's obviously this has been talked
about on a bunch of different websites.
Yeah.
Speaking of politics,
scary shit fucking at the way you're
going to be the atlas performing arts
center.
How come you're not at the improv?
Those cons are they're not booking,
you know,
they don't look like what kind of
ridiculous shit is that?
Listen,
you dirty bitches.
Just because ari shaffir came up at the
improv does not mean that he can't go
there and headline I be.
Or like allison.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Headliner ari should fear.
Listen,
we'll make you a deal.
We'll pump it up on twitter.
We'll talk about it on the podcast.
That's what we're doing with the atlas
performing arts center.
And you know what we're going to do?
We're going to pump it up the same way.
Well,
I'm gonna pump up this weekend,
August 13th in milwaukee,
Wisconsin at the palace theater.
Oh,
that'll be fun.
Holla at your boy.
I've ever played Wisconsin before.
Um,
yes.
A long time ago.
Brian.
We still need to put that um,
denver data up on the ustream page.
It is on this one.
You hit refresh.
I did.
Good.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Something happened when you go into
denver.
Oh,
that's September 23rd.
What are you playing?
A,
the paramount theater boy tried or used
to do the comedy works,
but Joe Diaz cannot get booked at the
economy works and I get tired of going
to denver and everybody asking.
Yeah.
And uh,
you know,
is wondering,
promoting that or somebody else should.
I think she's said something to do with
her to go.
She can't stop.
Can't stop Joe Diaz from coming into
town.
I'd say it's like,
what do you guys do when that happened?
Twenty years ago.
Version of that story too,
as far as the store is that the girl she
was on the stage,
she jumped off the stage.
I kuchta and I asked him my hand for a
brief second and comics talked to
understand that that was sexual
harassment.
I bet it's a lot of comics just not
being cool with crazy stuff that happens
at comedy clubs where somebody's
complaining.
Well,
Joe Diaz style craziness.
Joe diaz is perfectly fitted to the
comedy store when he talks about that
girl that he got to suck his dick every
time she got on stage and the belly
room,
she had to suck his dick.
Some girls,
but she quit.
She quit comedy and then she said,
uh,
she said a letter to the comedy store.
So angry and he did that and joey talks
about it and laughs or animals.
I lOve it.
Well,
he was probably running it like that in
Colorado,
you know,
knowing that joey,
that we know from back in the day he was
making a party,
just make it a party and someone
panicked and you know,
some fucking really white guy probably
just couldn't handle it.
I mean Joey diaz was a criminal from New
Jersey who all of a suDden lived in
Colorado and it was robin people with
machine guns and fucking rock kidnapping
cocaine dealer,
but not real kidnapping.
I just robbed someone's cocaine stash
with a machine gun has so much better.
I love it.
So much hArd.
Yeah,
it was crazy.
It's amazing how nice he is.
He was so hard.
He's like,
it was a straight criminal.
It's great.
It's a complete change.
He went on a 10 minute rant about how
the weed sucked.
The last time we had a podcast,
he was calling it a weed stuff to.
Hannah was a hat company from the laurel
and hardy show,
like calm them down for five minutes for
explained it over and it goes off.
I'm right.
He was gone,
so could you give me this fucking saw
hannah?
We'd just fucking side.
And I was like,
what is he saying?
Is that like a,
you know,
joey diaz.
Mr pronounces words.
I thought he was saying like hannah
Montana,
we'd call it sauce,
but I thought he was callIng it.
Yeah,
me too.
right?
You did.
I like,
I like that name better.
Anyway,
susko hannah weeds hilarious.
But what it was is,
here's a tip,
ladies and gentlemen,
don't do this with your weed.
Don't grind your weed up in a,
um,
a coffee grinder.
I've done that for a little bit and it's
a matter of how many times you press it
down because it gets chopped up really
quIck.
Have you put it in bowls or vaporizer
like that?
Uh,
that is good move.
Yeah.
Vaporizer at works like that because you
don't have to worry In a vaporizer about
sucking air through,
but when you roll a joint with it and
it's powder,
it's too hard to get oxygen through.
And so I don't think you'd get as high.
So that's what joey was responding to
the other day.
That and the fact that he was in traffic
for like an hour and a half getting
here,
hair screaming at his gun's bike.
You fuck.
And he made a video of it.
It's a layer it.
Yes.
And he showed it to us after the show.
So we're going to add that video to the
end of the blog videos that we do on it.
You go to joe rogan.net.
There's always,
if he sends his blogs,
videos sent to us it sounds like.
Yeah.
And if it doesn't,
if he lives down the street from you,
you can just go to his house and upload
it.
I'll just recreate it,
create it.
Why would you recreate it?
But what he did was perfect.
Yeah.
We said it was perfect and he's fucking
screaming at people going nuts because
he's stuck in traffic.
We're going to go with the buffalo
together.
You are when?
Next?
February 17th.
September 17th at the town.
What a ballroom.
You and joey,
who uh,
who booked this,
uh,
this guy contact us and uh,
literally working out the details.
It was just fucking.
Yeah.
September 17th.
Is that what you said?
Nice.
September 17th is a saturday.
There's a ufc that night in new orleans.
Oh really?
Yeah.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
that should be good man.
So what is the name of the place?
Town ballroom.
The town ballroom.
You own a well,
make sure you come on both.
You guys come on that week and uh,
and pushes a.
Yeah,
we know wIll do fine.
I have that wednesday open.
I'm not filming fear factor that
wednesday.
So we'll do a podcast with you and joey
that wednesday and we'll talk about a
lot that we can.
Yeah,
I think I can try to hit New York for a
few days after that we got to do a
daytime podcast to nighttime podcast.
Joe,
he gets too angry when nighttime.
Oh,
how's it going?
Is that why you did my time?
Yeah,
I had a film all day.
It's going easy,
so it's easy as fuck man.
The easiest job in show business.
Three days for an episode there.
There's,
you know,
the easy stuff is the where they have to
eat things or do those usually take a
couple of hours?
The other day is take like five hours,
six hours and set up.
EverythIng is fucking easy man.
It's,
it's going into a show like the people
were running it.
There's a long.
Yeah,
they ran it.
The,
the,
the uh,
the old days.
So it's a single dose.
They know exactly what the fuck they're
doing.
So its easiness.
Yeah.
It's just a still getting easy money.
Wow.
What was that?
I know it just dropped off.
Yeah.
Oh,
you know what that is.
That's that limiter that we have on now.
Keep allowed to keep the joey diaz
limiter sounds from getting too crazy.
If we don't make any sense of drop stuff
extra hard.
It just turns off the mind like a prius.
Yeah.
It's like a shitty hybrid just stops
recording when no one's talking about
buying one of those
hybrid.
Yeah.
I'm getting alif,
alif oR a bolt.
One of the all electric cars.
yeah,
I'm sold on it.
All the details have read it.
You buy two batteries,
you charge one inch or house you
charged,
you keep one going to give you all these
tax incentives to get one.
Really,
if you got a home charger they give you
a ton more taxes than if I'm talking
about like four to 8,000
for each one to go towards the cost of a
car.
And then the fuck the amount of oil,
Texas virtually none of them has like
most like almost.
No,
no.
The other one that has completely
electric.
And how long can it go?
What?
So one of them's a hybrId.
Which one's the hybrid?
I think that's the chevy volt.
The voltage of the nissan leaf is the
only.
All electric car.
And so both with both of them.
Yeah.
I think I keep an extra.
You keep an extra battery in the car and
they said this.
They said more stuff can go wrong.
Wrong.
There's only one thing.
That engine is way simpler.
You just took out this battery,
put another one in that's there's
nothing can go wrong.
The way more can break on a regular car.
They have prius
is down pretty good right now.
Yeah,
they have an even better thIng.
Oh look,
I think.
I think if you're somewhere and you need
fucking energy,
you can't rely just on energy.
You have to have gas because what if.
What if this whole thing fails and they
decide to add,
fuck this.
I at least want your car debt and being
able to save.
What would it be?
One of these batteries become,
you know,
like they stop making the car,
the company goes out of business.
They've got a busIness just like pontiac
or just like all the other business.
Maybe they stopped.
They stopped making these batteries and
how that would happen to the bay for
$50,000,000.
how long would it have to be?
Well,
how long would have to be a.
It's around until you get a car like
that.
I,
I will get a hybrid.
I'll get a like a prius type thing or
like how long would electrical stuff
have to be around before you say,
okay,
it's going to be around.
It's not just going to enter to win.
It's a win.
All the batteries are the same for every
single car or what's the law?
We're completely happy.
That's the only time,
the
way I feel,
the way I feel where I know that there's
some sort of a peak oil situation and
we're slowly going to run out of
resources and electric cars will slowly
take over.
I fucking love driving a big fat stupid
v eight right now because I know this
is.
These are the last of the mohicans.
I never get any pleasure out of it.
My mustang to drive my mustang.
I'll let you drive.
You've been in that room before.
You want to drive it.
you'll get it once you drive it.
Once you get behInd that thing in that
aluminum block,
550 fucking horsepower.
The snarl of four inch tailpipes.
Can they not make a fast car like that?
It won't sound right.
It won't be right.
It'll be cool.
They have a tesla,
the tesla roadster.
That's very.
Yeah,
the tesla roadster is a very fast car
and it's uh,
it's interesting because it's a little
sports car,
but it's all balanced all.
Fuck,
I got a honda right now,
so I'm not getting that job anyway.
Right.
I know you're not getting the joy,
but you should.
You should you because you have.
You drive a have a five slash six speed,
right?
Yeah.
Your car is a manual to manual that
manual,
not a manual man.
You know what it's like to shift all the
time.
okay.
That's dotson olag manuals.
I liked them for cars.
I dOn't like them for traffic,
but I liked him.
I like him for real cars,
man.
When you drive a mustang and it's,
you know,
one of the gt $500 and a manual and you
didn't really go through the fucking
gears.
You feel it though.
You feel the mechanics,
you engage the gear,
you're selling a lot more,
how long you're going to go in overdrive
to downshift how much speed you can get.
You can't do that with an automatic car.
You're just hoping it keeps shifting
with the right time you have.
Yeah.
Well you can definitely.
The.
Today they have these called a double
clutch boxes like m three has a double
clutch box and what that is is an
automatic,
but it's a standard like you can set it
up to shift gears where you could rev it
up as far as you want and use the
paddles to shift gears like all the
ferrari so you can do yourself new fires
to the bicycle.
Exactly a little higher.
I'm still trying to speak to as long as
your heart's content,
but you shift with the paddles and it's
instantaneous.
The shifts are like franco section.
Almost many,
many cars have it now.
Porsche has.
It's called a double clutch gearbox
double.
What it means is it's actually a seven
speed with the m three has one and it's
a seven speed and what it is is there's
one gear that's inside one gear,
you're engaged one gear and then the
clutch will already pick up the second
gear.
So as you're shifting gears the next
gear,
it's like instantaneous.
Like when it,
when it releases the first gear and
picks up the second gear,
it does it with no,
like when you're shifting into a regular
car,
you have to go with a neutral to
neutral.
When you hit the clutch,
you put it into second gear and then you
release the clutch and now it's in
second that press on this thing you
don't.
It's first gen,
second game.
It's instantaneous.
That electric car.
How many?
How long does It take to charge a
battery?
Like 12 hours?
No,
not nearly that long.
You can charge it overnight.
You can sit.
You can have an ipod program that sets
it to charge during non peak hours.
Each charge is what?
Eighty miles?
No way more than that.
It's way better than what you think.
300 matalan.
You look into the stats about 300 right
now because right now you're asking me
to quote yourself and I don't know if
you guessed 80 and I don't know.
He got excited.
Notice he raised his voice.
So you want to look in here trying to
make points and stuff.
We're all just guessing.
I know I'm not the haters,
But at the point was to say like you
want to go 80 miles away,
way too little,
80 miles would not be willing to drive
to Texas.
Okay,
so you need seven batteries?
No,
you still up at gas stations?
They have seconds to you laugh and like
anyone's driving to Texas.
When the fuck is the last time you drove
to Texas?
He like 20 minutes trying to take a road
trip is one.
Okay.
Yeah.
Let's wait a minute.
Hold on.
Sorry.
This thing only gets 99 miles.
Nine miles total belief per charge?
Yes.
So you want to go to vegas?
Got ain't shit.
You just have to stop at 99 miles.
Charge for six hours.
How about that?
Here's what I liked that you got happy
that it wasn't as good as 300 miles
because it made the point earlier.
I'm just saying that if you're going to
get a car for the most part,
we get a mix.
You don't want all batteries.
What I'm saying,
if I didn't have 300 miles,
I would want a better.
If I get to go 300 miles on a charge,
actually this is up to 100 miles,
which means you're probably.
That's way too low.
60.
How much is the volt?
That doesn't seem like it should be out
in the market yet.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what?
The epa has rated the nissan leaf a
driving range of 73 miles per charge
range will vary with driving habits,
conditions,
weather and battery age,
but that's whack and it's ugly as fuck.
Dude,
I'm taking you to the ford website and
show you a gt 500.
You know what?
I do want to get some of that.
I want to get one of those little ones.
The little baby markers.
Smart cars just for like driving to the
store.
just totally easy to park.
Smart,
smart cars.
Not as bad as you think.
Safety wise,
no fun.
You don't feel the growl of the va and
get that store you don't like.
That gives you a thrill that that's what
I'm getting on an open highway are how
old are you?
Thirty seven.
You're going to like it in about five
years.
What?
Open highways,
you know what's great though?
Windy roads,
that's when it's great to have a fun
car.
I get too scared now.
Don't even have to drive fast.
You don't have to drive fast.
Used to feeling of,
you know,
just a little bit of a windy road and
make sure you're controlling the car.
You feel the tightness of the
suspension.
Okay.
The nissan volt.
Jesus christ,
I mean 50 miles.
Fifty miles.
Fifty miles on it's fucking battery.
Oh,
that's where you can't even get to work.
The all electric rang the epa.
All my god.
Is it electric range?
According to the epa is 35 miles.
Yeah.
You get stalled traffic on the four or
five.
The total range is 379 Miles.
So that means if you got to fill up a
gas,
your fuel economy is through the roof.
It's 93 miles per gallon.
That's incredible.
So that is um,
that's if you go a half an hour.
Yeah,
37 miles.
Thirty seven.
Yeah.
37 miles an hour.
TheY have the recharge thing,
like where the breaks retarded it.
okay,
this is what it is.
He goes,
it's 93 miles per gallon in all electric
mode.
I don't understand that.
And 37 miles per gallon in gasoline only
mode.
So I guess you have the.
You have the option.
So a combined gas and electric fuel
economy.
Reading of 60 miles per gallon.
I'm pretty fucking good man.
My car gets 15 and that's what it's
rated at,
so probably gets 10.
my card is like 27 or something.
I need to switch my car but I want an
suv and I don't want.
I might get the.
I think they have to do so much,
but this is kind of interesting though.
The chevY and it.
What else?
What it does is it operates the battery.
It operates on pure battery power until
it's battery capacity is depleted,
at which point it fires up the engine
and then the gasoline engine powers and
electric generator to extend the
vehicles range so that how it operates,
it mostly operates on electricity as
long as you have enough power in there.
So it's almost like that's why it wasn't
the same as it was like how.
How is it different if it's half and
half,
it's not quite happening.
It definitely seems like a better move
than the volt because at least you can
get gas.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The.
Yeah.
The volt is better than the leaf because
it's.
The hybrid seems to be the way to go.
Especially 76 miles.
Unless you're just drIving five miles
back and forth to work.
There's not,
that's not really realistic at all.
Any road trip is you're fucked.
I always,
yeah.
I always think what if I had to go on a
road trip and I know you say there was
some sort of 70 percent charge you can
get in 20 minutes really quick charge on
don't know one of them,
but um,
but the problem is you don't want to,
you don't want to stop and have to do
that in you miles that's weak.
But this thing sounds better.
This thing can go 370 million miles and
this is like a normal car.
You just go into the gas and it can keep
going and that one keeps shifting,
changing.
They just have weekends,
engines sound like shit.
I know that these are for
transportation,
but this is,
we're going to miss this.
Something we're already missing in the
transition between the gasoline powered
cars like you,
you,
you know,
you get in an old mustang smell.
Um,
and yeah,
we missed a smug.
We definitely do.
But we also missed the analog connection
between the person in the vehicle.
This is a fun connection between cars.
my aunt got up,
she got some nice parallels like a lexus
or infinity or something and uh,
it had an analog clock on it and I was
like,
well,
why don't you have that?
She goes,
because it's class here.
She was so excited to have this thing
and I was like,
wait,
it's harder to read.
Why that class?
Why don't you get a stick shift then?
What are you talking about?
Writes in cursive.
I was like,
well,
that's not easy to read clock.
They do that with lexuses.
Maybe with alexa,
you're looking for a split second.
It's your time and it's not supposed to
figure out what were the big hand is.
Isn't it funny that digital watch has
never really caught on?
No.
Especially if you want to be classy,
like get yourself a rolex.
Get yourself a nice cardiay yeah.
Not so much easier to read.
No more exact.
You don't have to wind it.
What is it?
What is it about that?
It's all aesthetic better.
They used to make core with digital
speedometer and it was so weak.
Oh really?
You'd hear the growl again?
Put the fucking foot and gear.
You put the clutch in.
Engaged ball.
You see the digital numbers.
Like what kind of stupidity is this?
Something about it.
You want to see that needle move?
You want to see it.
You don't want to just.
Did they ever remake of the kuda?
Because that's what I got.
I saw at brand new kuda the other day or
barracuda.
Yeah.
Other people.
So yeah.
The challenge.
Challenge challenge.
Yeah.
Barracudas shape the,
the shared a lot of the same body shape
in a lot of the same challenges.
The hemi engine.
Well,
you know,
there's some would have somehow.
How are those cars?
Because that was doing awesome.
Chris has one.
Excuse me.
Oh bob,
or did you know that?
Aubrey,
I'm going to tell you this before I
forget.
He runs a nail.
His website.
Oh,
I found out about men.
Uh,
yeah.
My girlfriend told me about the same
dude that sells,
that sells alpha brain,
which is legit.
It's fine.
If you made fun of guys wearing nails on
that podcast,
I believe at one point.
And I looked over and I'm like,
the clam out hearing these.
He did?
Yeah.
You said something and maybe that made
fun of dudes getting pedicures.
Yeah,
but I think or like a ordinary people
that get nail polish now.
I'm like,
I love over.
Yeah.
You made some of the guys getting
pedicures.
I've met a ton of guys like manicures.
I'm sure I do iT all the time for
manicures,
you know,
it's just like guys who get like a clear
gloss over.
You're just trying to look pretty.
I know.
Taint used to do
his nails,
you know,
he's always painting his nails guys
anytime.
I was in college and a little bit
afterwards.
Well this guy runs on website.
Yeah,
it's a,
I forget what it's called.
The alpha nails,
nails got alpha brain.
It's got alpha nails for that.
Do it like I love to put a little bit
before going out to suck some dick.
Dave navarro was on howard sTern the
other day and I was listening was
fucking really compelling,
especially one part where they said
that,
you know america's most wanted.
They found his mom's murderer whose
mom's birthday's.
Navarro's mom found the guy on america's
most wanted and that show got canceled.
Yeah.
You know the america's most wanted man.
They were talking about how many people
have been caught because of america's
most wanted.
It's a lot fucking directly because of
that.
They showed,
got caught.
He got caught directly because of that
show.
Amazing.
Well,
If you think about that show,
man,
that does more good than how many people
watched millions.
Millions of people are watching it and
then that person is a fucking target.
Now turn this off.
Everybody turned stands,
man.
People you know,
you go,
you're working at a gas station.
This guy pulls in.
Yeah,
look,
get changed for 20.
Like you motherfucker and you make a
phone call and next thing,
the next exit.
Bam.
Good luck.
You can't go bonnie and clyde today,
man.
It's too hard.
Did you hear about those kids in Florida
that tried them?
Try to do about a stripper and her two
brothers,
one of the fucking shooting spree and
robbing banks had automatic weapons and
shit and they to start out in Florida
and they just got caught in Colorado in
a shootout.
Really?
The broad got hIt in the leg with a
bullet and yeah,
they were shooting at the cops and they
didn't kill him.
That's another car.
That's another warm country.
Warm area,
Florida.
It's another warm area.
Storms dude.
Oh yeah.
Florida,
Florida.
Florida is the land of the lost.
We've said it a bunch of times,
but it's true.
That is the most vacant city or the most
vacant state?
The most.
There's something mentally,
mentally,
emotionally.
They're detached.
They're fucked up.
It's a.
It's a weird.
I like going there.
It's a lot.
A lot of fun.
I mean,
there's.
Don't get me wrong.
There's a lot of cool people there.
My fucking parents live there.
It's not that everyone there is shitty,
but there's so much.
So many people moved to Florida to
escape and to hide,
you know,
somebody,
New York gangsters went down to Florida
to lay low.
It's like whether,
you know,
it's like,
it's like it's way worse style.
It's way worse.
It's more like,
I would say it's,
it's like the worst parts of parts of
rural Florida.
Jacksonville area or in between tampa or
something.
Land dog.
that's where we're going to put our
keeper.
Had like real spells.
That's we're going to put our compound.
Yeah.
We're goIng to make it all out of cement
and steel so that know her it down like
the um,
like the evil,
um,
justice league that they have with that.
Yeah.
They had an evil justice league.
There was some swamp land.
Really not horse America,
because if you wanted to be evil,
you'd go to a swamp,
right?
yeah.
No,
I could see them.
It was like the mix of plex,
that the anti
superman.
I think that's tough.
Watching this documentary on the Congo
and people actually tried to move to the
Congo,
like wealthy europeans came well because
there's immense,
immense amount of resources in the
Congo.
The Congo has diamonds and gold and
there's this,
you know,
minerals,
there's a lot of money to be made in the
Congo and that's why there's so much
civil war they're going on right now.
So many people getting murdered in the
Congo because they're trying to rob all
the shit out of that region.
That's why all these women are getting
raped.
I get the Congo is a terrible,
terrible place,
but at one credit for raping her,
like,
what are you doing?
Like because of the goal they want to
take over villages that women
internalize.
The men won't demoralize the men,
the,
uh,
a shoot the young men and rape the
women.
But,
um,
the,
these wealthy europeans at the turn of
the century tried to build mansions
there.
They,
all this wood court,
they have these beautiful mansions in
the Congo,
completely abandoned.
It was overrun with jungle and monsters
and fucking spiders that act in packs
and big cats.
And chimpanzees,
I mean,
you can't fucking just build a house
there,
dude,
and play polo in your backyard because
you got some money,
like a lot of really wealthy people.
Like this is an amazing place.
We're going to build a home here and
this is back when people didn't even
have,
you know,
they didn't even have like powerful
boats,
you know,
they didn't have planes,
they didn't have cars,
but they're moving fucking big boards
and all this,
uh,
you know,
construction equipment in there and
they're trying to build houses in the
Congo.
That's just like building in a swamp.
You know,
the same thing.
Look at these body kits for these
electric cars.
If you searched google for a body kit,
they have like little cafe,
boz,
little porsches.
Look at that little,
little mini cars.
The court vet whole.
No,
no,
no.
These you drive.
Scroll up,
scroll up,
scroll up a little bit.
I can scroll up a little.
You put like a different bottle one that
corvette
gt.
That is,
I Mean the career gt,
the porsche.
That is nasty.
And that's like a smart car.
Yeah.
It's just like body kits you can buy for
the smart a lot of money.
Do those look pretty,
pretty fancy schmancy?
Yeah.
That's pretty sweet.
But the batteries for that,
that leaf thing,
you're talking about $10,000
a battery.
$10,000
a may take eight hours to charge.
Eight hours.
Whoa.
Yeah.
They'd have to get a little better than
those little smart car.
Fake ferrari's are the time.
I see you mentioned this all driven
around with these things.
Yeah.
It's $10,000.
You get $5 back.
The government immediately you get 5,000
back from the government immediately.
Yeah.
So it's $5,000
for a battery?
No,
for the charging.
Could I would get this new charges?
Those are fucking bad ass a cool.
I'd like to talk.
I like to go to the goldman.
Yeah.
Like that.
Why doesn't someone make like a real one
like that?
Like make it fast?
Yeah,
right.
I'll give it some power.
What looks like a micro machine.
That's what.
That's exactly.
They look,
someday they'll be laughing at all this.
You had to actually go somewhere and
just beam up
old man.
Go to the baCk.
Yeah.
People will,
will have on the body.
They'll have some ability to fly through
the air and manipulate,
you know,
manipulate the matter around them to fly
around.
That'S gonna.
That's,
that's definitely gonna happen.
Some Day they're going to be laughing at
stupid people in their cars.
They rely on traCtion to slow down.
What if the rubber pop.
I know they were getting into accidents
all the time.
They didn't blow outs.
They were idiots.
Yeah.
The lady,
we look at people on horses with the
horse legs broke.
You gotta shoot it.
No,
your car.
Your car.
That's what if the car dies so you can
just get rid of it.
Let's just get rid of it.
They just got rid of their cars.
Like someday there'll be no need to
recycle because we,
we,
we will never,
you know,
we don't ever look at resources that
way.
We'll,
we'll,
we'll be in harmony with nature.
Maybe.
Maybe not.
And we were just fucking pigs.
Gluttons.
Maybe we are here to eat the sandwich
world and maybe if the sandwich.
That was my thing and my beginning of my
showtime special,
but I said that I look at people like
mold on a sandwich.
You look at mold on a sandwich,
you don't see individual mold spores
with individual personalities.
If you were an alien life form
completely alien to earth and you saw
human beings,
you would go there as a growth.
This is a girl.
You look at cities and you know the fly
into los angeles.
He looked at the the nature.
Look at the ocean,
the mountains.
It's all beautiful and natural and then
you see cities.
It really does look like something's
growing there.
And I said,
well maybe that's what we're here for.
Maybe we are just like mold or sandwich
maybe over here to we're here to meet,
eat the sandwich.
You know,
it's really.
Maybe that's it.
Maybe we're here to fuck things up.
Probably noT.
Maybe we don't have a fucking purpose.
Build the robots to kill us.
It's just,
it's.
So.
It seems to be the process of
complexity,
like we're a part of the process of
complexity and that definitely seen if
there is a purpose or a need or a
direction that everything's going in,
it's going in that way.
everything is getting more and more
complex.
It seems to be inevitable.
It seems to be an ethic seems to be
this.
The way things work well,
when you think about it,
of what everything.
Everything is moving in a direction of
complexity.
It's all a lot more advanced really
fast,
but the whole universe is.
The universe starts out with a,
you know,
a small,
tiny spot,
smaller than the head of a pin blows up,
expands multicellular life forums.
That book comes intelligent sent in,
able to change its environment.
Then it starts changing at a rapid pace.
It all seems to be a direction and
ethic.
So what do you think?
What are you going to do differently?
I can't do anything differently.
I think what we're trying to pretend
that we have it solved and we're trying
to pretend like,
oh,
we as people we need to get together.
It would be nice if we were cool to each
other.
That would be nice.
It would be nice if we could all enjoy
our time here and.
And you know,
and not be concerned.
That would be nice sources.
Yes.
Either way before those codes,
even when it's not nice at san francisco
is still people are cooler.
Nicer.
Yeah.
Well let's.
Because they moved away from the east
coast.
Everybody initially landed on the east
coast and the ones who couldn't take it
anymore,
so fuck this.
I'm Going west and they kept going.
I think the one thing that we can do,
everybody says y'all we need to,
you know,
people need to figure out a way to work
this out and we need to work together to
change the way that.
I don't know if that's gonna I have a
feeling that what we're doing is
natural.
I have a feeling what we're doing,
war corruption,
the depletion of resources.
It seems to me that every other animal
that does fucked up things,
whether it's hyenas kidnapping dogs.
Have you ever seen that?
Or if you're seeing that not heinous.
Baboons kidnapping puppies,
so they raised puppies.
They have feral puppies that go.
Yeah,
they become dogs.
They stay with them their whole life and
they guard their camps so the babylon
and sleep at night and the dogs bark.
It's intense.
It's complicated though,
you know,
but.
But people look at it and they don't go,
oh my god,
what is this?
They go,
oh,
well this is natural.
The baboons have figured out that if
they kidnap these puppies,
they can get these puppies to guard the
camp.
It's like natural for humans to war with
each other.
Yes.
One hundred percent natural doesn't mean
it's good for us.
No,
it doesn't mean it's good for us,
but it's sorta means that it's going to
see.
But you say good for us.
You're talking about,
you're talking about you.
You is definitely good for those people
that are getting money out of the war.
You know,
you say it's not.
But for those dick cheney characters
that are getting billions of dollars
while a little brown people get bombed
on it is good for them.
They profit for yes.
So it is natural for someone who is
unscrupulous to pursue those,
those paths because there's money to be
made from it.
And I think that,
you know,
even though my print out short,
should it mean it's,
it's frowned upon for a bunch of reasons
because we're all in this together and
you know,
and we all think that people shouldn't
be treating each other like that and I
completely agree,
but on a natural starfish or how's that
work?
Never hear that thing where it's like a.
The guy picked up a starfish on the
beach,
throw it back in the ocean.
yeah.
It was another friend was like,
there's thousands of starfish on the
beach,
like you can't possibly hope to save
them all.
Like what difference are you making?
Right?
Then he goes,
well,
it matters that wants to go first.
So I'm more of like an individual,
smaller level.
Somebody to traffic.
Yes.
Well look,
anything you'd really easy to make a
difference.
Anything you do that makes the world
better,
whether it's telling jokes to make
people laugh,
making a song that people like,
just saying hi to someone at the grocery
store and it gives them a nice warm
smile.
AnYthing you do that's positive is good.
Anything you do that helps people is
good.
Anything you do that makes this
experience better,
but ultimately it's all temporary.
The entire experience of life on this
planet,
for everyone,
including your,
your future children.
It's all completely temporary.
Enjoy it.
Yeah,
you got to enjoy it,
but the direction that it's going,
if you were looking at this direction,
if you are looking at human behavior,
if you were looking at any other animal
that was behaving like this,
you would assume that it's natural.
When bees make beehives,
you assume it's natural.
This is what they do,
and ants make some giant complicated ant
farms.
You know they make Incredible anthills
man,
monstrous giant constructions.
We just assume that it's all natural.
When,
when human beings act crazy and selfish
and delusional and fuck up the
environment and war with each other and
dropping bombs on each other,
we should probably assume that it's
natural.
We should probablY assume that this is
a.
This is what this species does.
We just are so cocky.
We think that we can avoid.
Our nature were so cocky.
We think that we can manipulate our
nature and maybe we can recount.
That's what I put laws out of.
It just kind of slows it down.
It's.
It stops it from being completely
chaotic and that mean most of the laws
are set up so people can have more fun
and enjoy more time here and have more
pleasure and less to protect both of
them.
Yeah,
yeah.
Less,
less,
less pain,
more pleasure.
Make this this transient moment feel
better for the people that are
participating in it,
but when you get past that,
man,
what is it?
What the fuck is all this welcome?
War never ends.
How come?
How come we're always coming up with new
reasons for it?
How about corporate corruption?
Never ends 2011.
This belief,
this $16,000,000,000,000
bail out thing that we're hearing about,
you know,
how come you know,
how come there's so much money missing
in Iraq and Afghanistan?
It's billions of dollars and cash went
over there.
I don't know where the fuck it is,
but yet or rolls on,
despite all protests,
corruption rolls on despite our pro.
All protests on people agree with it.
Yeah,
they was another Corruption.
But with war,
a lot of people agree with it.
It's because they're ignorant.
They don't understand me.
Go read war was a racket by general.
Smedley butler.
Nineteen 33.
This fucking guy,
major general,
major general in the marines wrote,
wrote this fucking incredible book and
incredible paper about,
uh,
about war,
about how all his career.
He thought that he was protecting people
and trying to promote freedom.
And really he was just making things
safe for bankers,
making things safe for oil companies.
It's all about money and that's why he
wrote war is a racket,
you know,
the idea of a racket being something
that's corrupt and set up the only army
really because other people have
artemis.
Yeah,
exactly.
Otherwise it's really important at all.
Yeah.
Um,
what a fucking bummer.
Stupid way then.
So on a positive note,
you're,
you're fucking touring all over the
country now,
man.
you,
you've completely over the last,
like year and a half.
You completely broken through.
Yeah,
I feel like I feel like a,
like a more of a draw,
just like,
I don't know if that's happening.
you're a real comic now.
How much of that is your podcast?
A lot.
That's the only been for four or five
months,
but that four or five months.
Big pockets too.
It helps us a shit ton.
Um,
and then I feel like my comment has
gotten better.
It's hitting those sort of a new little
down and dirty
norton and all the internet exposure.
you've got a lot of internet exposure.
Yeah.
Well this podcast is just like being on
a radio station.
It's like being on there
radio stations,
like every time I go on stage now
somewhere there's people workout sets.
I don'T promote it all.
Just,
you know,
comedies with him and then it's like you
hear people clapping,
I getS your heart.
Yeah.
it's nice.
It's really Nice.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
You alwaYs needed something.
You always needed that and we always
thought that it would be something like
comedy central.
I met robbie from just for laughs.
Told me this like two years ago when I
went.
He was like,
yo,
I ain't going to do a special man.
That's just not going to be your path.
Look at your comedy.
Really.
You think comedy central?
Let me think about it.
To comedy central.
Put my special on.
I know it's kind of ridiculous,
but he was like,
it's just not going to be your path.
They're not going to book you,
so fuckiNg find another waY.
Right?
I dunno.
Maybe it's internet stuff.
I have no idea.
That's what did it.
It's all human merit.
Definitely.
Yeah,
for sure.
Selling out because of it.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
it's a,
it's a totally new ball game man and you
know,
and it's,
it's a much more intimate relationship
with the people that are listening first
of all because it kind of goes right
into their ears.
They're wearing earplugs and shit a lot
or they're in their car alone and it's
like you're sitting with them in traffic
or you're sitting with them while they
work.
Sorry about traffic.
So maybe you're in waiting to use the
treadmill and someone's talking,
just give out to standing on the
treadmill,
talking to the fat girl next to him,
get off the treadmill.
Um,
but it's,
it's the,
the connection is different.
It's different than.
yeah,
there's never been a time like this man.
Tons of people in Canada don't have tons
of people there.
More than one.
But number one in Canada all the time.
We're number one on itunes of all
podcasts.
We've been on a bunch of times.
I met that guy president,
remember him and kept scott.
Yes,
I met him when I want.
It's kind of cool,
like it used to be a comic.
yeah,
yuk.
Yuks is a good change to,
but I think they keep comics were doing
other chains,
you know,
they do it.
It's annoying as shit.
I just don't.
Well you don't have to,
but that's weak.
You have to.
And vancouver's and cooks anymore.
I think that one's done.
I think I just did it though.
It was another club.
I forget the name of it.
Absolute.
I don't remember guys going to be mad
because he was a nice guy and I hung out
with them.
What?
The yucca,
I think it's called absolute comedy,
but my max out because it in toronto.
I don't know.
It's in vancouver,
but it's a,
it's the same place.
It's still a great tight little blocks
off the main street.
Yeah.
Whoever knows it.
Just send it to me on twitter and I say
it because I feel bad.
But uh,
we did it.
Um,
when I was down there we did the,
uh,
the club and then we went over and did
the next day we did it after the ufc.
Yeah.
It's fun,
man.
It's great.
Yeah.
It's fun to go to work.
Have somewhere.
Oh,
I did it after the williams.
I did it friday night.
Yeah,
it's great.
And Canada is just the one of the best
place to fucking perform of smart
audience.
Like they understand what comedy is
where you're supposed to be quiet and
listen in graphite crazy and then be
quiet again and listen.
They just understand.
I know,
it's weird.
It's like a festival stuff too,
but it's just like,
it's not just a sMall.
Those are the gigs we did always well
behaved.
Especially even your show.
Yeah.
Savage,
they don't really.
There are different types of animals in
Canada.
They're like smart cottey it comedy
audience animals.
Yeah.
And so you're doing a lot of just for
laughs yet you just did the montreal
comedy festival,
right?
Was what'd you do after you did your
storytellers shit up there.
That's another
thing you've gotten really good at.
You've sort of organized a series of
shows.
What's all storytellers shows where you
get up and people just,
it's a theme.
Everybody has a material they do about
whatever fucking theme it is and made
that part of my game a lot stronger.
Your storytelling part.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
because you could stretch out on that
stage,
right?
Yeah.
And I have to keep coming up with
stories and figuring out where,
what funny is,
you know,
and like working at them like I got to
fucking show and four weeks I have a
story.
I don't have one.
that sounds good.
Yeah.
You were hurting for a long time,
man.
Trying to break through the comedy
scene,
but now you've become a legit
professional comedian.
Yeah.
I met these people that run the comic
strip in edmonton.
The husband's like a comic and the wife
has just runs it,
you know,
and uh,
it was like,
oh,
nice to meet you.
Another 15 year old son was like,
to me it was like,
can I take my picture with you?
Amazing.
And I was like,
yeah.
You were saying,
who is this kid?
Serious,
you're fucking ruined in.
This kid's brain is going to get beat up
by some mexicans.
He's going to be out.
I haven't gotten that far taco.
But there's mexicans up there and do
know is there's a job,
there's mexicans,
they'll find a way,
man,
they'll find a way.
I do.
It's called comedy mix comedy max.
Yeah.
Thank you.
The whatever.
That's the guy's name,
but what a brilliant fucking thing.
Twitter is,
man.
Just being able to ask,
ask a question like that.
It's like your own little wikipedia.
How many a friendship now to followers?
19,000
dollars.
Shit.
Samson.
Follow our issue.
Fear.
Ladies and gentlemen,
a r I s h a f f I r and follow red band.
I'm a little dirty though,
so if you're a christian you don't.
Yeah.
That was funny that you said some girl
got kidnapped,
a 14 year old girl who kidnapped and he
goes.
I remember sometimes when I was young I
wished I had a different family
that's too far and I thought about it.
I was like,
alright,
well maybe.
And I was like,
no,
I appreciate it as a job.
It's not my own experience getting red.
Fortunate that that girl got a kid now.
But you were talking about writing.
If I write it like,
oh god,
did you have kids?
I have kids and I didn't really like
that.
My favorite is my favorite is the people
who let you know there aren't following
you on follow,
so rude.
It's like,
all right,
if you don't like it,
you can just go.
You're.
You're trying to make some point.
I don't care.
It's totally cool.
Not that like me.
Yeah.
I had a bunch of matter.
Unfollow me because I was making fun of
easter ones,
so yeah,
the easter bunny rabbit.
Every easter.
Just a piss your faces.
don't say that to eddie bravo.
He loves rabbits.
Really?
Yeah,
he's on a rabbit kick.
My lover.
I frank.
Harvoni has a rabbit.
Yeah,
loves it,
but I got a bunch of my yard and now I'm
going to eat them when the shit hits the
fan.
boom.
Schelok lock.
Boom.
So just to reiterate to her this
weekend,
August 13th,
we're in milwaukee at the papp's
theater.
That's this saturday night.
It's me and joey diaz.
Oh,
rare combination support.
It's one of the few places where joey
diaz apparently has no warrants.
Just hasn't been there.
It has actually told me he's played some
cool places in Wisconsin in a long time
ago.
He's been there back in the day.
He knows apparently some great places
where we can get good italian food.
That's what he keeps rant about the
fucking spaghetti and meat sauce.
So,
uh,
that is,
this weekend,
August 13th.
This saturday night we're fucking fired
up the papp's theater.
It's supposed to be a beautiful place.
Then september 20 thIrd at the,
uh,
paramount.
What are you doing?
September 23rd?
Um,
nothing.
ari shaffir will be joining us on
September 23rd.
Ari should is also coming.
That's the denver.
Why denver?
Colorado is always amazing.
Zam was pitches and there's courses at
ufc the next night we're already will
want to be because it's John Jones
versus quentin rampage junior.
Motherfucker at altitude.
Very difficult to have a five round
fight title,
altitude.
A title fight in the fucking place where
the air is.
Thin is shit.
I love total funds.
Fuck yeah.
You're doing.
Denies how important it is.
Do to when there's a fucking ufc on
versus this weekend.
Got.
I'm the luckiest guy on the planet.
Thank you everybody for the birthday
tweets.
Thank you to the flashliGht.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I'm 44 bitches.
That's right.
You can still be retarded at 44.
You can still be a child and never grow
up.
It isn't.
It is possible to be a peter pan.
I will not mature.
I will stay this way.
As long as my body stays healthy,
I will not get any more cranky than this
is how I will get off my lawn.
KidS had that exact age.
Thank you to the flashlight.
If you go to joe rogan.net
and click on the link for the fleshlight
entering the code name,
rogan,
you will get 15 percent off the number
one sex toy for men and then you could
shoot loads with a big smile on your
face knowing how much money you're
saving and you can use that money to buy
the new alpha brain pills that were
selling from onnit.com.
O n I t everY single fucking report I've
gotten back as positive.
All these people that have tried it,
I'm getting testimonial after
testimonial brian's been using.
I've been using iT.
It's safe.
It's not dangerous.
These things that have all been.
Everything has been researched.
There's a frequently asked questions
thing that we're putting together for
[inaudible] dot com,
but there's actual science behind this
and it's not like that fucking pill that
the bradley cooper took in that
limitless movie.
It's not going to make you into a
genius,
but it does make your brain feel good.
It makes you feel clean.
It Makes you feel like you have energy.
Chris or mark.
Aubrey morgan.
Aubrey says it's good for hangovers.
I haven't tried it for that yet,
but it is good for for pen name.
What is his deal?
He's fucking out an iowaska trip and
changed his name.
He dId the podcast.
I was pretty gay.
Gay with a g,
h e y like protein.
Whey holla at your boy in ottawa who
gave me a bunch of pot and mushrooms.
Yeah,
I'm not sure.
Circle.
Whoa.
You just took mushrooms from some dude.
It was pretty cool.
If I get a perfect circle,
the band really to put on a cool shot.
I was never really into it as a band,
but I was super into it so I'm like,
alright,
let's do it.
Is that with the dude from tool and he
states only one lead singer way in the
background in darkness himself at all.
Yeah.
Maynard is a weird guy.
I read a lot of weird things about him.
It was a culture that he's good at
jujitsu,
so.
So I take him.
I said,
man,
I like you.
You are just like me.
One of the other,
my friend.
You'll get in there with spa.
You'll put your neck on the line.
Thank you everybody for tuning in.
Next week we got kevin motherfucking
smith is going to be a gas and the
return of duncan trussell and I'm holla
at your boy.
I love you bitches and thank you very
much for everything.
Thank you for tuning into the podcast.
It means the world to me that you guys
enjoy it.
And uh,
it would be pretty fucking stupid if
we're doing this.
Nobody was lisTening to everyone in the.
What are we doing by,
by big kiss.